The answer is going to be that while that is effective for building
an audience and it gets people on your side, it also leaves you
like if you're totally ruthless in these moments, you have no
humanity, people don't really care if you get straw manned or
actually completely misrepresented, right? Like you can be treated
anyway if you're going to be like without humanity talking to
other people.
Not the approach that I should take. Why why should I try to
be anything other than completely ruthless in all moments?
>> Right. Probably even if you have humanity talking to
other people, you'll probably still it's politics. They'll probably
still not care even if you get misrepresented. But you get a
few people who will stick around and like kind of take your side
on things. >> You do a matan accent. What is his first
>> You bugs. Oh. Uh you bugs, don't you? Uh you're gay.
You're gay. You're gay. You're gay. That's that's my matan
So reacting to stuff. Incredible stream. Okay. Give me a time
stamp on that place. Did you give me a time stamp? 1 hour exactly.
Oh, you did. Perfect. We'll pull it up after. Or maybe we pull
up pull it up now. I don't know. So, it's uh it's Aaron and Pisco
talking and then Smug joins. I I don't mind taking a a detour
here. His ability to what? To do anything. To do anything. I've
known like three people that I think are kind of like Pisco.
And they're all they're all too tightly wound, right? They're
all really tightly wound. And that's maybe their biggest downside,
okay, is that they're way too tightly wound. and they they will
you know things will be high stake when they could just chill
right no worries I got it so so that's possible that he is a
little too what tightly wound I think that even if they're tightly
wound they can figure it out they're willing to put so much effort
in they're willing to put so much time in with such focus and
such intensity that they'll figure any problem out you can throw
any problem I worked in software engineering for a long time
I I know people like this you can throw any problem out can be
a problem they're totally not well verssed to solve and they
will figure it out because they are just capable of spending
like60 16 hours in a row hard focusing on it. I know a lot of
people like this. I think that's I think Pisco is fully capable
of that personally.
Isn't his main goal to Isn't his main goal to sway people? So,
I can see what you're doing here. DNA sample is fine. Um, isn't
his main goal to sway people to his political position? Does
that make Does that go handinhand with being a unable to make
jokes or talk like a regular human? What part of Pisco's the
broad body of Pisco's content makes you think he's not capable
of joking or acting like a human? I that seems wild to me. like
it just you haven't watched any of his content where he like
laughs and jokes around with people. That that just seems wild.
I think you probably have a very very like boiled down body of
understanding, right? DNA sample. I just I don't I don't think
you actually um have watched quite a lot of his content. He's
perfectly capable of joking. He's perfectly capable of taking
jokes, of understanding them, of engaging socially. I'm I'm telling
you. Yeah. He pulled Kathy and he laughed, right? True. Oh, Downey
with a with a clutch example. Yes. Pulled Cath in, laughed, knew
he was trolling, right? Knew he was trolling, was laughing, was
dying laughing. Um, the idea that he's like a total social a
who has no like capability of getting these jokes is very goofy.
I understand though why some people would be very invested in
believing that, okay, in trying to spread that. This guy's like
too too like convince anybody of anything. No, he's not. No,
he's not.
I do get it. Have you guys not seen a show with Aaron? Yeah.
The whole time, right, Ozel? Yeah. Um, I think Pisco has done
a fantastic job, by the way, and this is another point in his
favor, is I think Pisco is significantly
like more inhuman in his approach. Like I think he was significantly
more hostile, significantly more aggressive with people like
a year and a half ago. Like Pesco was he would go hard on people.
I just remember when he like literally Rage Pope didn't answer
one of his yes or no questions once and he immediately goes,
"Destiny, kick him out of the call. Kick him out of the call
now. He's cap he's totally incapable of engaging, right? Like
and he just went off he talked about how rage phobes like too
engage with any topic ever. It's like okay that's like one way
he's engaged, right? Deserved maybe. But I just I remember that
and like I've watched him I watch him argue with people who are
like actually
when they call into his stream and he's very gentle and calm
with them. He doesn't get like aggressive with them. He's like
grown so much in that way that I'm pretty confident he'll be
fine. I don't think he's got a problem there. But we'll uh we'll
pull this up. I think I've got it. Let's check it out. This is
the this will be the Aaron and Pisco convo. Bacto said starts
around right here. Let's check this out. And then we can come
back to Econ Boy. We can come back to actual like policy prescriptions
and cuz I I like this conversation, but it seems to be moving
pretty slow. And I don't mind like going back and forth at all.
I like honestly I kind of consider like some content idea of
like if I've got two three-hour videos I almost wonder if I shouldn't
like write notes and like sort of talk about where we left off
and go like 30 minutes between each like let's say we have two
2 and 1 half hour videos or something we go 30 minutes between
each just to keep it fresh cuz I feel like when you do really
long content pieces it can you can lose people right you can
lose the engagement um DNA sample I just think maybe you haven't
watched a lot of his person his content like personally to be
honest with you and I don't have to call be like a total if you
if you're here in like good faith. You're not just trying to
say like, "Oh, Pisco is not capable of joking cuz uh I need Pisco
to suck." If you're not saying that, which I'm not saying you
are, okay, it just seems that way a little bit, but I'm not saying
you are. If you're just here in in good faith, then I I would
just suggest you watch like some of his stuff with Aaron where
they joke around. They've had some very funny clips together.
They bounce off of each other very well. Yeah. Anyway, let's
uh let's check this out. Yeah. Keep in mind, we maybe I'll come
back and discuss this with people. just the idea of bouncing
between pieces of content and not going like an hour or two hours
through things. Uh, you have thoughts on the disagreement he
had with Josiah right before Aaron joined? I think that when
when they both started talking about the Star Wars universe books
that they'd read and how they were like checking each other on
nerd knowledge, I was like, "Oh, this is uh crazy.
This is uh this is Oh, boy. Every everybody here's a nerd." I
I'm just not a Star Wars person. Okay. I knew just I was a Star
Wars person. I didn't think Pisco was a Star Wars person, too.
I think uh probably if I had to weigh my opinion or or give an
opinion, I think Wu beats Cidius legitimately and it wasn't just
to pull Anakin over. >> Who let him in? Who Whose fault
is that? >> Wait, can you share your screen? What are you
going to show us? >> Give me two seconds. I'll be right
back. >> We got lots. >> Go to the bathroom real
quick and then I will get some water. >> Backwards. Okay.
Give me your thoughts on how Matan Timool Alexstein vice what's
his name? Gavin. >> Gavin McKinnus. Yeah. >> How'd
that go? How do you >> Yeah, I really liked it. I So there
are a couple things maybe,
you know, that you could ding me on. I think that I was going
into it super serious to to kind of combat the troll cuz I thought
that they were all kind of trolls. You have Stein, Matan, and
McKinnis who behind the scenes was a bit of a troll. He's like,
"Oh my god, Pisco." And then like took a selfie. I've been dying
to meet you. Right. So that uh and I was like And >> is
that your Matan impression? >> No, no, that's Gavin.
For a second it sounded like you had this like vaguely ethnic
accent. Can you do a matan accent? What is his first >> You
[__] bugs? Oh, you [__] bugs, don't you?
Uh, you're gay. You're gay. You're gay. You're gay. That's that's
my maton impression. Um, >> okay. That's your impression.
But how come all you could manage was >> bugs? Oh, you
dogs, don't you? >> Oh, I thought, dude, I I just made
I Oh, you guys your answers. The truce actually got me so badly
this time. That's the first time they've ever got me. Usually
I realize pretty quickly that I'm muted, but they actually got
me so badly. I was making a point. I was making a good point.
I'm like, "Oh my god, everybody agrees with me." Oh, this is
so right. This is so Oh my god. Yes. And then I'm muted. Ah,
I'm going to go I almost have to go for a walk to reset my mental.
I didn't get my drink. I just I came back from the bathroom.
God damn it. Uh I'm not going to mute this time. I won't even
mute my mic. I'm just going to walk away for two seconds. I'm
getting some caffeine. I'll be right back. [__] [__]
>> Hey, you're gay. You're gay. You're gay. That's that's
my maton impression. Um, >> okay. That's your impression,
but how come all you could manage was to keep the stick firmly
up your ass? Why didn't you pull it out and have fun with him?
I don't get it. >> No, because because I'm in a environment
where
I No, I was trying to because I'm in an environment where no
one is willing to give me the benefit of the doubt in terms of
the the audience hates me. like uh and I have to rely on like
I'm the only live there >> and in that environment I'm
not confident in my natural like I don't think that I'm naturally
funny. I don't think that I'm natural kind of talent and so I
don't want so I'm just going to I play >> I I don't think
I'm that witty when I'm like not in a comfortable envi >> this
is why he'll succeed by the way. He can admit he can admit every
fault immediately. This is why he'll win. Just so you know >> environment
you know I don't think I'm that witty. I think that I can't hear
you Aaron. Aaron, you're shut some of your mic. >> Why
is this happening? >> This never happens. >> We're
gonna fix this tech issue stuff, you guys. Hold on. Oh, wait.
Can you guys hear me? Test test. >> Can you guys hear me?
>> I can hear you. >> Okay. Okay, >> man. I've
got uh you just real quick, I've got like all kinds of thoughts
about how this idea that you can't be wrong on the internet about
how that like
actually up like everything, dude. It's actually such a cancerous
position to come from that like oh everything you've ever done
wrong I'm going to hold against you for the rest of your like
it's so cancerous it actually destroys so much of internet discourse
it's so rough it's like it's actually central to like everything
that's up I'm not joking it's like central to it so stupid like
and you you just have the people who like don't want to engage
in anyway we say something >> I'll like I'll think of some
stuff I'll think of some stuff around it no no no I I believe
this is True. What red 7 473 just said, you can be wrong, you
just can't look weak. I agree with you entirely there, but there
are a lot of people who are very invested in telling you that
being wrong is like the end of the world and it's just not. It's
just not at all. Like that's the thing is I can be wrong on so
many things. I don't mind being wrong, okay? I just show up the
next day, I fire up the stream. [__] it. Let's go.
Right. I think I think that's like the only way you can handle.
It's the only way you can like survive. I don't understand the
people who think they have to be correct on everything. I just
don't get it. >> It's so inhuman. >> You're like,
"Oh, I'm struggling in these environments." It's like, yeah,
because you're going in and you're telling yourself,
um, oh, it's serious. Like, I got to I got to keep my focus.
But like, you're not factoring in the environment because >> Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, Kenny. So, I don't think so. You shouldn't
be wrong confidently on things, right? What you should be is
you never want to be the person who's like wrong confidently
in something and then you have to like warp public perception
after the fact, right? That's such a position to be in. You should
be able to know when you're wrong, admit it, and move forward.
You shouldn't be taking super harsh positions on things without
without like knowledge that you're correct, right? Thoughts on
the fell for it again award meme. That's okay. I like that a
lot. And then a lot of boomers. It's like every meme. It was
really good and then boomers picked it up and now it's like me.
Can't be wrong and serious in a room of funnier people than you.
That's true. Sure. Red 473. That's true. I think that's absolutely
correct. Absolutely correct. I don't know if you're saying that
was what Pisco did, but I would say that's very true. >> This
is not a really like serious sit down debate. You're outside.
You've got a crowd full of hogs that are like screaming and banging
and who? >> It's not outside. It's inside a bar. You can't
see everybody. It's >> Oh, Felford to this subject.
Felford again. Award like what? You'd have to go for the same.
>> Okay. Well, the point is is that it's clearly a casual
environment. you've it's like a 4v1. I don't envy. >> Oh,
also the other thing that will make Pisco successful is that
Aaron is never going to hold back any of her criticism. I don't
know if Joanna holds back her criticism with Pisco, but I don't
know if Aaron's capable of being nice in these situations. Okay,
this is Man, I don't want to It's not even capable of being nice.
It's like u do I want to be personal? I get this from like Cherry
quite a bit. It's not that she's not nice. It's that Cherry will
be like actually she'll say precisely what she thinks the problem
is and won't pull a punch, right? And that can feel bad in the
moment sometimes, but it is always for your benefit like going
forward. And Aaron will do the same thing for Pisco where she'll
just say, "This is what went wrong. This is what I think went
wrong and you need to know it because not because I want to hurt
you, but because I care about you, okay, this is what went wrong."
And I think um that you'll always get better from people like
that. You you should have people around you who are capable of
criticizing you. Yeah. Exactly. Red 473. They should be encouraged.
It hurts though. Okay. It hurts. You have like a bad conversation
with somebody. You have like a bad read on content or something.
You're just totally wrong and then you have to hear about how
up you were like how how much you up. That's not easy. Okay.
That's pretty That's pretty tough. All right.
You want you want those people to be nice to you, right? Oh,
yeah. Sure. I've seen this. For what it's worth, I haven't been
able to change Pisco's opinion except on football. I think she
said at some other point. But but like it is for your benefit.
it is to make sure you're you're not going to make the same mistakes
over and over again. It's somebody invested in your long-term
growth as a person rather than somebody who's just like trying
to make you feel better and trying to like extract something
from you in the moment >> you in that position. But that
being said, I don't know that you should just kind of have this
fatalistic approach of like the audience hates me anyway, so
I may as well lean into that. Why not try to like, you know,
so basically I I think that trying to like lean into Yeah, [__]
dogs. If it's like if and do like a little joke on that and like
yeah, [__] Just you could just say no, you don't
[__] dogs. You just say no, you don't [__]
dogs. Oh my god. Cuz you know it's a poodle. I think that that's
>> No, you should have been like no, I don't. But maybe
Donald Trump does because that and that's in the Epstein files
and he doesn't want it released. Let's talk about that. >> Yeah.
I don't I just don't like uh I don't know if I if I trust myself
to make that land. I think it'll I I just wanted to play it super
straight given what was going on. >> Straight. So you hate
trans people. >> See, Eron's Aeron's going to show him
super straight and appeal folks. because that's who you're trying
to get in with. Okay. Everybody says you're trying to get in
with the MLS, with the communists, he's so just exposed right
now that he is trying to get in with the
>> Okay. You're witty. I don't consider myself super witty.
I think that my like I when we're on a show just like having
an exchange, you and I like I feel a lot more loose, but in that
environment, this guy's like an >> Oh, hold on, hold on,
hold on. Told you he wasn't witty. Wait, are we doing self ID
now? So, so either Pisco isn't witty and you believe that, but
you also believe Aaron is not an ML,
right? Is Aaron an ML
or not? Cuz she says she's not an ML. Pick one. Pick one. >> Actual
one like professional troll. >> And I'm not going to play
his game and then lose. Like I don't want to like come off, don't
worry about it in that way. And so I I made a strategic decision.
I made a strategic I made a
I made a strategic decision not to address anything that wasn't,
you know, with with respect to the What Pisco is engaging here
is what we affectionately refer to in the streamer world as coping.
He is coping right now. Okay, this is this is cope. This is copium.
This is coping. We're watching him cope
>> And that's what I did. And you can say that, you know,
you would have felt more comfortable. I mean, what would you
have done in that situation? I think that that it's kind of like
similar to a whatever podcast situation. So maybe >> I
was going to say I've done that and I made the mistake of doubling,
tripling, quadrupling down, not reading the room and I got my
ass kicked off. You know, I can live or whatever, but I do think
that that's not how I'd handle it now and like next time I went
back or whatever that I didn't handle it that >> So you
would lean into it. You would be like, "Yeah, this is how I see
an evil." >> Yeah, I think I think that you have to. I
think that I think your instinct is right to not just immediately
default to >> although now I remember I remember um that
one debate where it was I should go try to find that clip of
it's it's Cherry and Pisco arguing and Cherry's like I don't
even know what a Zionist is and she like says something else
and then and then Pisco's like so you admit this and she's like
no Ninja
it's like it makes me I need to go just the sound clip alone
is so funny >> I got to like you know be witty in response
or whatever because that can lead to like pressure >> just
it was him being super serious when Cherry was like kind of messing
with him a little bit, right? It was just another it was another
situation where she was kind of messing with him, right? And
Pisco was super serious and not even messing with him. Just like
a little bit of I don't know. I I think she thought he wasn't
being he wasn't engaging very well and so she was going to get
>> makes like a joke not land or whatever. I understand
not being comfortable with it, but when they like are still when
they're like still hammering on it, it's like okay, they're not
going to drop it, so just address it and then move on. >> Yeah.
I mean, I don't know. I think that there are a lot of people
messages I got which said something to that effect. There are
also a lot of messages that said, "I appreciate the fact that
you kept it serious." And so I don't know. I don't know what
the general sentiment is. Maybe some people >> already
agreed with you. >> It's possible. It's possible, but I
I think that there's a nice contrast there between people who
you could say. >> So this is the thing is you can keep
it serious on the topic, right? Nobody wants him to go, "Haha,
yeah, you're joking about deporting like people I care about."
Nobody wants him to do that, right? I'm totally fine with them
playing it straight on anything about the border, on anything
about illegal immigrants, on anything like that. But when Matan's
asking about whether you dog or not, just say, "No, I didn't
dog." Yeah. Uh, wait, your mom last night, she's a real [__]
Like, I dude, I don't know. There's like a million ways you can
go, right? But you can [__] around there. You don't
have to keep it serious there. You can you can totally break
out of the series there. Go into whatever you want. >> The
whole show is built as a debate show. And Alex Stein, you know,
for better or worse, he is the like a more serious MC. And of
all the people there, Alex Stein is always like the least. Wait,
did I say she wasn't a communist? I thought she said she I thought
she said she wasn't an ML. She is a communist. She wasn't an
ML. That did I misspeak when I spoke earlier?
She is a communist. She's not a Marxist Leninist. Was like exactly
what if I miss if I said anything but that then I was >> Crazy
right-wing person there. And um the previous encounters with
Will with Will Chamberlain and with with this guy Good Logic,
those two that those were serious discussions. And so I I'm coming
into this >> not under the impression that it's going to
be a complete show trollfest.
Okay. Who
who Oh man. No. I see. That's the That's the issue. I said this.
We talked about this last night. If you missed the 11 hour stream
last night at the very end, we pulled this stuff up, right? And
that was my argument was like I I'm somehow thinking that Pisco
didn't understand who these people were cuz realistically they
must have advertised it. They must have told Pisco who's going
to be there. From who was going to be there, you could tell what
kind of event it would be, right? Like if I just looked at that
lineup, I go like, "Dude, they're going to be like this Maton
guy. Have you ever watched any of this Maton guys content?" I
would say from a base position, you should actually understand
who these people are, right? if you're going to go on panels
with them, especially if it's like a Tim Pool panel that you're
like getting ready for. I think uh some amount of like, you know,
scouting report is necessary here for Pisco, don't just only
prepare your own stuff. Do a scouting report. Get get some intel
on the other people and what they believe so that you don't get
caught off guard. >> That there's one troll there that
I want to, you know, neutralize him. And he >> Oh, I just
gave an example. DNA samp
that your mom thing. It's that it's a dog, right? Dog mom joke.
Yeah. Easy. his same stick. Um, and so I I was treating it like
I was treating the Will Chamberlain thing and trying to focus
on the issues. I mean, that's what worked for me before. You
can say you don't agree with it, but you know, I I know that
some people Oh, this is rough. This is still cope. This is still
cope. Pisco. Pisco, wake up. Pisco, wake up. We're not discussing
whether or not it was a serious thing or whether or not being
serious was a good strategy. We know being serious was a bad
strategy. We know that because of who was on the panel. Nobody
else was going there to be serious. When you say, "I wanted to
approach this to be serious. I wanted to be very serious." You
you seem to all of us because all of them are trolls, right?
That's that's the thing. They're all trolls. So, you seem when
you're like, "Oh, I just going to go there and be serious cuz
I thought it'd be a good tactic the same way I would with Good
Logic." You've had other discussions with Good Logic.
Agree with you. I'm not saying that those those people are wrong.
In that moment, you know, seeing what Matan was doing behind
the scenes and what Gavin was doing it, I felt a little outnumbered
and what I wanted to do was just neutralize the memes and just
be play it as straight as possible. >> No, no, no. Okay,
I'm focusing on the the criticisms first, but >> dude,
there could have been really funny ways to play that straight,
too. He could have Dude, if he hit them back with like a caricature
of himself,
right? I think there could have been funny ways to even lean
into that stuff, probably. Right. Were you not harassing me backstage
with the same question? you're really going to bring it out here
like right you just start saterizing yourself. I don't know.
>> I want to say I think you wiped the floor with these
people. I think it's I think obviously the facts are on your
side. They don't have anything to say in response to it. So there's
your flowers, right? It's it's none of that. It's just wondering
like are you you have to go and like what's your goal? And it's
like do you want to rally the troops? And you know you're not
going to reach this audience. You're definitely not going to
reach people on the panel. But >> I see how handled Alexstein
well. As much as I hate Destiny. Yeah. As well as you can.
It was a different kind of situation. I wonder how Pisco would
have handled that exact situation. That was very different. It
wasn't Alex Stein really trolling. It was him like yelling in
his face that he's a
like kind of weird. Alex Stein was kind of unhinged,
>> But you can absolutely destroy them and prove to your
own audience or people that like uh hey yeah, I'm not going to
put up with bull for MAGA. I'm not going to try to play their
games whatsoever. I'm going to hold the line. This is how it
like and this is how I'm going to present the liberal side and
arguments or whatever and show that they're unserious or [__]
clowns. That's one way of looking at it. That's one approach.
I think it's your approach. But I also wonder like you do want
to try to reach people.
>> I might unwind a little bit. I think you you have a
point there. I think I think people have a good point. >> That's
what I said. Tightly wound. Guys who work this hard are always
super tightly wound. And like they will take everything seriously
until you like push them out of that zone. They're usually witty.
They can usually joke. Like I think when he's with Aaron, they
can joke around. They can around. But yeah, you got to push them
out. You have to actively like push them out of that situation.
He's got to figure out how to do that, right? You guys ever read
Name of the Wind, Wise Man's Fear? He's got to figure out how
to get his mind in spinning leaf, okay? He's got to be spinning
leaf in a moment, okay? He's got to move with the wind. Got to
be very very open to wherever the conversation goes. >> And
I I have maybe too much of a stick of my hand, and I get that.
>> Oh, also I believe uh Alpha Kilo, so I'll I'll highlight
this comment really quickly. I've heard that once it got into
some kind of like serious more serious conversation and what
once Matana chilled a little bit. I I've heard he did quite well
after that. It's like the first 40 minutes are like kind of rough
for him where he's getting with and then they sort of settle
into stuff and he actually does quite well after that is what
I've heard. I didn't watch the whole thing. >> I think
that I'm trying to calibrate a little bit because I think my
best appearance on Tim Pool was probably that good logic appearance.
I think I did that very well and and I played it off a little
bit more looser, a little bit more funny, a little bit more nice.
Um, >> it's a controlled environment. He's on >> Exactly.
Exactly. >> That makes it easier. >> That makes it
easier. Um, so maybe I would and I think I perform better in
those environments than on a live stage. And a live stage, you
guys can't really hear it, but it is I come across maybe a little
bit more shrill. Um, but it's because it's super loud there and
the mics don't necessarily pick it up. Everyone is like yelling
at me like 80% of the time when I'm when I'm talking. And so
you have to put that into perspective that it seems like a >> dude
DNA sample. You seem really like you're like dead set on having
this opinion. You don't have to like agree. You could you could
like I guess totally disagree. I've seen like a lot of indications
that he can totally loosen up. If you if you totally disagree
and you're just going to hate this guy, that's fine. You don't
have to watch him.
Watch me. I can totally loosen up and joke. Let's go. I'm being
super shrill and repeating myself and all that stuff, but it
just when you're on that stage, it's a very different environment
than when you're on a in a podcast studio. And so I would definitely,
I think, loosen up if it's in a one-on-one pocket. And and I
think that shows in my previous even when I was doing the the
New York um studio stuff when I was brought in. >> Dude,
it's so it's so inhuman of him to like to not get ner to get
nervous. It's so inhuman for him to get nervous and have a bad
appearance. Oh my god. >> And afterwards after the interviews,
I think I loosened up a little bit. I think I was providing >> when
I choked on that water. Okay. When I when I drank that water
incorrectly earlier in the stream, that's when I was loosened
up. Okay. I didn't even ban the guy who told me I was the for
drinking the water incorrectly. Okay, I was super loose. We were
feeling it. We were in the zone >> jokes and stuff, but
it's a lot easier and I feel more comfortable doing that when
it's like a one-on-one with a cameras right there as opposed
to in front of an audience. And then like I'm not a comedian.
I don't feel comfortable like telling jokes. My timing is so
maybe in that context I can learn some some more techniques or
loosen up a bit and get some more confidence there. But I appreciate
the criticism. I do think it comes from a good place. And I think
you're probably right that in terms of calibration, I could have
been a little bit less serious, a little bit less like uh DNA
sample. I just totally disagree. I'm I'm going to respond one
more time. I think you're saying saying these things are like
set in stone and I just don't see it that way. Right. And I don't
think I don't think anything Pisco is saying Pisco is like beating
himself up, right? Or he's like saying this how I think of myself.
Uh, unfortunately he doesn't he just doesn't have I think he
doesn't understand what he's good at, you know, necessarily totally
without bias and he's best and he he feels like he's most effective
when he's in total control, but he's fine when he's a little
out of control, too. He is uh and he'll realize it. He'll figure
it out. I just I totally believe that people will uh I totally
like I just have no concerns about it, right? It seems totally
fine. Yeah. Anyway, sticking to >> Well, because the only
I think you should, you know, you go into you, you want to be
serious. You want to be the one that's actually forcing them
to take the conversation seriously. But once you can see that
like, okay, you're at the point where you're starting to exhaust
their efforts and that like the more you kind of try to bring
it back, the more incentivized they are to just poke it, you
lean into it cuz they see like at some point he's going to break,
at some point he's going to break, right? But I think if you
kind of you can like take the wind out of their sales if you
kind of like, okay, you play along for two seconds and then like
right back to it because then that shows the audience like, hey,
it wasn't for me being unwilling to joke back with them or be
chill, but we did that and I'm trying to move it back to the
thing that we're here to talk about and they just like don't
want to do it. And then it's genu then I think people can see,
oh no, he's not just being like a stick in the mud. It genuinely
is these people just like they have to go there because they
don't have anything else. Yeah, and for what it's worth, no,
I hear you. For what it's worth, Tim, and I don't think that
we should necessarily take Tim's advice on what's appropriate.
Tim thought that I did the right approach, um, given what he
knew about Maton. Um, but that said, I I hear what you're saying.
I think Tim just got clowned on super hard by Maton, too. Like,
realistically, if you if you don't want to or if you don't think
that's like the good thing, you just curate in the future going
forward, right? Which kind of appearances you make. Like, I think
uh it's hard. I don't know anybody who has actually gone on Maton's
thing and done like really well and looked like totally fluid,
totally not put off balance at all. I actually don't know, right?
I actually I don't know. I don't know who's got on his show and
like actually basically just been perfectly on balance and good
to go. Tim was willing to be clown though. Maybe it didn't seem
like he wanted his beanie taken, but I >> think you have
a point. >> Sam Hyde. Okay. So, so like the guy Maton like
looks up to like Maton's hero who totally [__] bases
his entire bit off of Sam Hyde the the one guy
the one guy
the one dude I will say everything DNA sample is saying is actually
exactly what the people who dislike Destiny said about him when
he talked to Adam Freeland for the first time like that he totally
got goofed on like he looked like a completely a antisocial
talking to Adam Freriedman the first time in that Discord all
disagreed then, disagree now. Uh I see the potential for both
people in terms of their comedy. So
>> people got frustrated with the uh with the jokes as
well, even given what I did. But I think that there's maybe some
opportunities to win some people over in the audience who who,
you know, maybe wanted someone who's a little bit less, you know,
serious. But I hear you. I hear the criticism. >> I have
a viewer that wrote an entire dock saying what you did wrong.
Are you open to hearing them out for a few? >> Is that
Wait, a viewer. She's not talking about Did she just call Smug
Bug a viewer? There's no way, right? There's no way. She just
called Smug Bug a
>> Okay, they'll join in a bit. Okay, but
>> you're allowed. Was that >> Smug Bug getting Lil
Broad right away. Aaron used to come on his show. Now Aaron is
the person. I have like a viewer over here. I have a viewer,
you know? He's just a viewer. Random viewer. >> Okay, I
guess it was it was for me. Whatever. Okay, I got a subscription.
Thank you, Ponkod, for the subscription. Okay. What else is Let
me share my screen. Let me share my screen. >> Oh, let
me look at it. Quick thoughts on Bill Crystal. I don't know.
I mean, he like I think he was like >> Israel first. Israel
first. Bill Crystal writer for New York Times for a while. And
I like that he's anti- um Trump, but I don't really know that
much about him. >> Did you see this? Clinton subpoenaed.
Every everyone else's uh headline for this is uh the Clintons
have been subpoenaed, but for the New York Times, I've noticed
that they just kept it to this
article somewhere, I suppose. >> Smug who? Smug bug's going
to be here. Okay. This is going to be like, don't you think I
did like good in this place or something and Smugg's going to
be >> "Skip next. Skip." >> No, I don't think it's
suspect. that it's part and parcel for the New York Times to
present to not just you know present the most uh juicy little
tidbit or whatever because that's not the only part of this story
that's relevant but >> was bombed hospital was bombed and
the >> oh for uh when it comes to Israel Palestine yeah
I expect nothing less than that that sort of sh um but with this
yeah I was actually not that surprised that that's how they chose
to report on it oversight committee issues subpoenas for epsene
files the committee's Republican chairman requested that the
docs from the justice department and former government officials
be delivered by August 19th So, this was earlier today for to
the DOJ for or sorry, just I'm just going to start skipping through.
Unfortunately, this could be interesting. >> I'm just going
to keep skipping through until we get to um >> we could
maybe cover some of the the Trump stuff. I know that Trump like
fully spent tons of resources to fully redact himself from the
Epste
the Epste stuff with all these people. So I don't necessarily
even have a that
funny though if like the subpoenas or whatever and nothing comes
at the campman >> did wrong. Oh smug bug you got the whole
dock you did the dock on what you did >> you [__]
up you disappointed the leg. >> Okay so we've got you know
the authority on being normal and it's going to be Smug Bug.
Smug Bug's going to come in and tell us how to come off as totally
normal to Pisco. Yeah. All right. I could you know. Okay. Okay.
I Uh-huh. Yeah, I believe it. I believe it. >> What's up?
>> Okay, smug. >> Hello. How's it going? >> What's
up? >> How you doing? >> Good. How are you? >> Not
too bad.
The occasion.
>> One second. Of course I up. There we go. >> Yo,
what's up? >> I dressed as a liberal lawyer. Okay, I'm
>> Um, yeah. I think I I hope he just said lol. Did Pisco
not realize Smug Bug like made an whole art piece to make himself
look like he's got Pisco's like backdrop and theming? That's
like a lot of effort. What the Actually, we had we had a conversation
before Pisco and it was kind of the same thing of I think you're
bad at talking to the right sometimes. I think that the Tim thing
was Well, I guess I guess the first thing I want to know is what
your goal was. I know everyone was talking about this already,
but like what was the what was the point? What did you want to
do there? I wanted to give some schlop for the libs to to to
see and um to basically just argue and raise my profile to to
get people to see like how scared these mother are about Epstein
to see you know basically how to win these arguments. I don't
know. I mean it's multifaceted. One to raise my profile. two
to have good arguments against I don't know conservatives and
uh and three to actually you know go engage with the with the
right and and make them face some of their contradictions which
I think I tried to do. >> Okay. So did you have any intention
of like appealing to Tim's audience? >> I don't know. Um
what you mean like you mean the the people who are physically
there or in general? >> Well yeah I mean the people who
are physically there the people who would watch it from the right-wing
perspective from the Tim perspective. >> Sure. That's a
that's a goal. >> Okay. All right. Fair enough. I get I
get that you have to like work with multiple goals. So there
might be like something that you do that only serves one and
doesn't serve the other. So I'm not saying you have to be like
perfectly consistent the entire time. Do you think that um conservatives
have like a higher or a lower bar for being internally consistent
than like liberal values
>> Uh I mean obviously lower bar a lower bar in general
is the entire idea of being reactionary. What is the purpose?
Dude, I just wish I don't want to do the Socratic method. Smug.
Smug. Just say what you want to say. >> I'm not sure. I
don't know. All right. You don't know where the liberals are
more inconsistent in their like internally held views than a
than a conservative is. You think conservatives are roughly >> My
intuition is that liberals are are strive to be more internally
consistent, but that comes I'm biased because I am a liberal.
But sure, I think that I don't have any proof behind it. I'm
just saying it's my intuition. >> I like that answer. >> That's
fair enough. That's fine. He's he's he's lawyering. That's totally
okay. I just Okay, so like the I think the original debate conversation
was the the the statement was something like >> Wait, you
just said I'm lawyering. I just I don't understand. What do you
mean when when you say I'm lawyering? >> Sorry. I mean
I mean you're not you're not committing one way or the other,
which is fair. >> I'm just being I'm just being honest.
I don't have evidence to show that libs fair in general are more
consistent, but my intuition is they probably care more about
it because my intuition is libs are more educated and my intuition
is also educated people want to be more consistent. But I don't
know that. >> Okay. But you don't think there's anything
about the liberal worldview that would like lend to you towards
being more consistent in terms of the beliefs you hold? >> Intrinsically?
No. Why would it? I mean, you could be a totally consistent.
You could be a totally consistent racist. If if what if we're
talking about is to hold an ideology without any contradiction.
Yeah. I don't I don't >> I don't I don't know that they
are I mean know consistency is something separate from like whether
we agree with >> Okay, that's fair enough. So the the reason
I asked that question is because I think that if you if you believe
that your ideology has like fewer internal contradictions is
that well first of all actually do do you think that your ideology
your version of liberalism has fewer internal contradictions
than like most other people's ide? Uh, I don't think he's being
too ser I think he's perfectly picked up the tone from Smug Bug
this time. I understand how you could get thrown off, right?
But Smug Bug, this is this is Smug Bug has these kinds of conversations.
I feel like he's picked up the vibe from Smug at this point to
be honest with you. >> It's way different than the Matan
panel. >> Yeah. I don't know. Yes. >> Okay. I mean
I mean I Yeah, I feel like I believe that. Erin probably believes
that about her ideology. The reason I bring that up is because
if you think that your ideology has fewer internal contradictions
than the opposing ideology, which you know, for this case, we
could just be like that room full of Tim idiots and Alex Stein
and whoever else, then I think that you could look at that as
like a potential way to attack them on their own basis. Like
you don't have to attack them through liberal values. You can
still enter their frame without carrying all of the baggage of
the liberal >> hang you think I did that with respect to
the the Epstein stuff isn't applying my framework. I'm applying
the EP the Epstein frame, you know, stuff is their framework.
They care about Epstein um, you know, much more than than I do.
>> I I agree. I agree. I think I actually I think that's
a really good line of attack. I think I think the Epstein stuff
makes a lot of sense to attack the right on. But I was talking
about the the Tim deportation stuff, right? Cuz you went in on
that debate about a what was the name of the guy who got deported?
I don't actually know specific
>> Um, and you know whether whether the Trump administration
should bring him back to the country. >> That was that
was the previous debate. Not not the most recent one, but yeah,
I did do that. But that because it was a debate specifically
about that with a lawyer specifically arguing the opposite. So
that entire the second conversation in the Timool was specifically
a conversation about Kilmar. That's the whole debate was about
Kilmar. The third one I didn't really focus that much on Kilmar.
>> That's fair enough. I'm I'm talking about the Kilmar
debate cuz I think I think that's where the second thing where
like >> Yes. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. Yeah. I'm I'm not I'm
not as familiar with the most recent debate. But the reason the
reason I think that you kind of walked into a bit of a trap is
because and I think you know this right like they don't care
about just or unjust. Like the first part of that statement is
completely worthless to MAGA because they don't believe in like
a liberal construction of justice or un or >> I think dude
Smug Bug has like gone way off. I don't think you have to argue
from their frame at all. I really don't. Right. I don't think
you have to argue from their frame even a little bit. You can
it's not about just unjust like Pisco doesn't have to talk about
it. You just talk about the facts and how they're misrepresenting
them. How like don't you feel clowned on? Right. I I guess maybe
maybe this should be maybe it could be a part of this. The way
he's framing it just feels off to me. The way Smug Bug's doing
it, right? Is like like you should make fun of them. Like you
guys you guys fell for it again. You really fell for it again,
didn't you? Like you fell for it again and now you're falling
for literally like oh this is like Russia gate. They actually
just added my name. You fell for it so badly. This guy just got
a thousand FBI agents to change the files and you fell for that
too. You fell for that? Oh yeah. No, he has to totally redact
himself. Guys, we have to keep the movement safe. Guys, it's
totally fine. This guy just say you would have let this guy [__]
your kid. Okay, just say it. Now, Pisco doesn't go down that
track, but I don't know. Injustice, right? They've like dismissed
the whole framework of like how governance works, how legality
and legalism works. Like, they don't really care about any of
these systems of justice. So I think by like trying to appeal
to a justice that every single person in that room other than
you basically has abandoned, you kind of ended up falling into
a bunch of traps where it seemed like you were essentially you
were just ingroup singling, right? You were showing well this
is a whole group of people that have abandoned basic premises
of like you know the the value of the value of a justice system
>> which is one of the goals for sure but I think that
it basically immediately turned the entire room against you in
a way that made it impossible for you to achieve the other goal.
And I think there's a way to thread the needle where you don't
have to give up so much appeal to the right in order to successfully
ingroup signal to your own liberals >> So help me with
that because so without changing the topic of the debate the
>> Yeah, this is probably true. Red 473, this is probably
true. I think there are certain things Pisco has a hard time
joking about and like that probably works for people that he
does that he does have a hard time joking about these things.
That probably actually serves him in a lot of a lot of cases.
There's like a couple options. You could not go on a thing with
um with Maton. You could not do that. Even with Gavin, you have
a real conversation with Gavin. I think with uh with Stein, Stein
and Maton are both kind of in the same camp. Matan's significantly
harder to have a real conversation with, right? You do need to
put stuff to the side if you want to go and have like a trolley
convo with those people while you're having drinks, you're in
a bar, all this, like a comedy club. That was like a comedy event.
I just don't know why. I feel like Pisco was invited to that.
And to me, I wonder who he shared like the the lineup with or
who knew where he was going. Like did nobody say to him like,
you know, none of those guys are serious, right? Was there nobody
was there nobody there who was going to say like, hey, you know
that like none of those dudes are serious, right? that like all
of those dudes are trolls. Their only goal is to be to troll
you like that. Like this, look at this Maton guys podcast. This
is all he does. He just like does his character and like messes
with people. That's the entire function of the podcast. It's
not even like just a little bit. It's like all it is. He's been
on them before with Alex hosting and they were way more serious
maybe. But like I'm telling you I'm telling you for a fact that
as soon as Matan and Alex Stein are there, it is not a serious
conversation.
Factually, those people are not serious people. Those people
will not engage seriously on the issues, right? Even like Gavin,
even Gavin won't really engage seriously, but Gavin's got kind
of the veneer of seriousness, right? I think this is just a this
is an event you probably avoid unless you're willing to let some
things go and joke around. So, I think it's perfectly fine to
have a brand where you don't want to let go of like people making
fun of uh Kamar Brego Garcia getting deported. It's totally fine
if you want to do that and you like that being your brand. That's
totally respectable. I think you just avoid that appearance in
those cases, right? If you can't let it go. >> Topic of
the debate, which was about Kilmar, tell me how I approach that
conversation from their framework in a way that's going to appeal
to them without coming across as a like little >> That's
a really that's that's a really good point. I think I think that's
fair. So, I think I think in that debate, you you do a couple
of good things, right, in in in service of like the ingroup signaling.
You say something along the lines of like if you have a problem
with illegal immigration on the basis of its illegality, you
should have a problem with illegal deportation. And I think using
the illegal immigrant frame as like an idea cuz that's something
they claim to hate, right? They claim to hate the fact that these
immigrants are illegal. So if they want to care about an illegal
immigrant, they have to care about legalism in some respect,
right? They have to have some care for it until you've basically
forced them to drop the mask. you check the audience and they
all say they're basically fine with breaking the law if it is
in pursuit of a you know a higher justice beyond like a legal
framework right yeah >> so I think from that moment onwards
and I know this is this might not this might suck for a lawyer
but in that situation I think legality should just not be a feature
of your argumentation like at all they've literally abandoned
every basic principle and I think if you were to listen to a
kind of normie Trump or a normie MAGA and they were to kind of
explain to you where they're coming from they live in a I don't
I disagree with like dropping this. I think you figure out how
to argue from their point of view how the law is important, why
following these basic legal principles are important. If you
abandon the first amendment for people who are like not quite
citizens yet, like you're you're opening the door. You're chipping
away the Constitution. You have to explain to them why it's important.
And you can do it in a funny way. You can do it in a serious
way. But here's why I take it seriously, right? You like having
your gun. I like you having your gun. cuz I love the Constitution.
Why do I love the Constitution so much more than you? Why? Why
do you Why do you hate this country? Right? You You go at them
from patriotism. You can totally hit them on why your beliefs
are valid from their point of view. You don't have to abandon
the law. They haven't truly abandoned the law. They think like,
"Oh, well, he's kind of like he's still kind of obeying the law."
And a court hasn't like said he's doing something illegal, right?
They they still signal about this. Just get them to say, "No,
I hate the Constitution, right? I hate the Constitution. I hate
the things this country was founded on." You can and you can
get people to do that, but then it's a totally different conversation
where they look super unserious to a ton of their audience, right?
They like Tim Pool people want to tell themselves that they're
the patriots. They're the people who believe in the Constitution
and that it's liberals who don't. You just you just make them
throw it away. You help them throw it away. Well, they've been
taught that the legal system, the justice system is not really
justice for them. They don't really believe that government can
actually help them. They don't believe that they're going to
get anything back from their taxes or from the, you know, from
their vote or, you know, they they're completely disillusioned
with the framework. So, the problem is that right at that moment,
I think, is when you basically say, well, you guys just want
Trump to be a king or a tyrannical fascist or whatever. I think
I did say that. >> And I think that >> you did say
that. Yeah. And I think and I think that was probably a mistake
because there is a fairly reasonable plausible position you can
hold in between those two things which is that you can believe
that the current system of liberal legal structures doesn't serve
you without wanting an unaccountable dictator. What they what
they feel I think is they believe that he has this like temporary
democratic mandate to do authoritarian things to break down a
system that doesn't serve them anymore. And >> this is
better. I like this. This is probably how a lot of people cope
with the fact that they don't care about their constitution,
right? Oh, well, there's a couple reasons. There's a couple ways
the laws don't serve us right now. And Trump's going to do a
couple things and then he's going to hand back power, right?
He's Caesar. Or not Caesar. Uh, is it Dialesian? No, no, no,
it's not Dialesian. Who's the guy with the cabbages? Who's the
Roman guy with the cabbages? It's not Dialesian. It is uh Roman
senator Cabbages. Who is it? It's uh Oh, it was Dialesian. It
was Dialesian. Okay. Uh, Dialesian is a guy who defended Rome.
He was He was elected dictator. He defended Rome. He gave up
his powers right away. Went back to the countryside, gross his
cabbages. Okay. Every time. Every time. He did it multiple times.
They elected him. They elected him. They elected him to defend
the republic multiple times. And each time he was like, "Yeah,
I'm a dictator right now. Yeah, there's nothing in the law that
says I have to give up these powers." And then he didn't. Okay.
Or sorry. And then he did. He did give up the powers. And he
went back to his little farm and he grew his little cabbages.
And then he died of old age. Okay. Happy. Many in the crowd agreed
that I think they would want people think Trump's like that.
And Trump's not like that. Not like that at all. >> This
as a temporary thing. They don't actually want him god king for
life. They want him to be given sledgehammer powers to like destroy
everything that isn't serving their purposes so it can be real
rebuilt in a way that does serve their purposes. So I think that's
how they feel about their views. But when you don't uh treat
don't allow space for their worldview to have this sort of plausible
foundation, it's impossible for you to appeal to them because
either they agree with the current legal framework or they agree
that Trump is a king, god king, emperor, you know, fascist and
there's no real in between, which is where they're actually sitting.
>> Yeah. Um, help me out because I don't think there's
a world in which I am convincing on the spot members of the crowd
with whom I'm debating. But maybe as this I don't know this middle
position help me out. So someone comes up and says so they say
I support the constitution. This is an exchange that actually
happened. I said okay you say you support the constitution. If
the constitution says that the due process clause requires that
these people get um some amount of hearing. Would you follow
it? And then he's like and I'm like yes or no. He's like no I
wouldn't follow it. So he just said he he cares about the constitution
and he also doesn't care about the constitution. So you're going
to have to help me out there. How do I in that situation as just
an example if you don't like that situation if you say that's
not >> power is not as centralized in the US as Rome sorry
the argument we're making right now or the argument that's being
had read 473 is that the reason people appreciate or understand
or look the other way for Trump's constitutional violations for
his basic flouting of the law is that he is trying to fix a system
that is broken. the laws are not serving the people and they
give Trump they they feel like they voted wanting to invest Trump
with the authority to break down those laws that don't serve
them and to flout them to better serve them as a people. Right?
That's what they believe now. That's not happening to begin with.
Right? But ultimately they think that Trump will just give up
these powers. He won't try to run for a third term. He's just
trying to do good things. Oh wait, I wasn't talking about Catus
or sorry Dia. I was talking about Catus and now 12 Clover Clover
over here in YouTube chat has said the name. I meant Catis.
[__] me. That's who I meant was Catus and I feel
really disappointed that nobody in chat knew that name to call
me out cuz I was being I was full of [__] there.
Okay. It was Catis I was talking about. God damn it. Yes. They
think Trump will just give this up. They think Trump you they
think you can just empower Trump to break the law to break to
with the constitution to ignore every other like element of the
what do you call it like the tripartite separation of powers
the the three the three branches of government he he Trump could
totally with it and he's just going to stop or he's just going
to stop no he's not he's not going to stop he doesn't want to
stop >> it's not a good example we can move to a different
one I I kind of remember most so how would you approach that
>> okay when when a mega person comes up to you and says
I I I support the constitution.
What is the first thought you have? Is the first thought that
you have that this is a person who lives and dies by the constitution.
You personally, Pisco, do you believe that
>> No. I'm >> before proven otherwise. >> I
I guess I'm I'm going to be honest with you. Like when this person
says to me, I support the Constitution. >> The minute I
hear that, I'm like, okay, so he has expressed a value to me.
I am now going to present him with um an inconsistency, a potential
inconsistency in which I will get him to have to deal or reckon
with or find some kind of way to explain that inconsistency.
And so I'm not really thinking about I'm I'm not really that
interested or and maybe I should be maybe that's your critique
or something >> in like oh when he says he loves the Constitution
he means something totally incomprehensible to me like I don't
understand what it would mean. I assume laticious gamer says
I assume most people don't even know what the constitution says.
You're right. You're right that most people don't know, but they
think they know. They think they have an idea, right? And they
think Trump's serving it
to love and respect the Constitution, but also not care what
it says or not apply it in some circumstance. And maybe he has
a a rationale for that. But I literally ask him, how do you explain
that? I think um so so help me out there. I mean, when I'm when
I hear I love the Constitution, the next thought in my head is
okay, there's an express value. now let me present something
and have him deal with >> I think I think that's fair.
I think that when I when I when I especially when I used to be
more of a debate pervert, like when I heard someone say something
like a right-winger say something like, I I I love the Constitution
or whatever, I would basically im the first thing I would think
is no, you don't. You're about to you're about to get shown that
you don't actually care about the Constitution. That like that
would be the first instinct because they're because they are
almost always they almost always are going to have less information
about it than you are. you're always going to be able to prove
a contradiction, but I don't know if that's helpful in appealing
to them. Like you can prove that they don't care about the constitution,
but I don't think you have to like do that in a aggressive and
destructive way. You don't have to like break down their existing
values in order to prove that they don't have them. Although
this is like the norm in in debate spheres, I think you can actually
get more success by leading them away from the constitution as
a value in a more constructive way. So instead of going, "Well,
it's not that and it's not that, it's not that," you like start
taking things away from them. They panic. They end up having
to like, you know, latch on to newly formed beliefs in the moment
because you've literally removed one of their like crutches for
for understanding their own ideology. Instead, I think you're
better off building on top of the Constitution. Oh, okay. What
do you like? >> I think I don't know if that's how they
think of it. That might be how like somebody who's very wellversed
in debate thinks of it if they're shown like a a major flaw in
whatever they think. But I think when conservatives get shown
that they're wrong on something, they go, "Well, I think you're
maybe you're like book smarter than me, but I know how I feel
and you're not going to change my mind, right?" I I don't think
there's like some latching on to new beliefs. I don't think they
need to run anywhere. I believe they just go, "Oh, yeah, you're
full of it. >> You are fake news about the Constitution
that makes you want to support it." Like what what about the
Constitution is important to you that you think what value is
the Constitution helping you enact? Right? So when you build
constructively on top of it, you're actually helping them build
a more sophisticated, complex ideology that you can then, you
know, gear towards your personal, you know, values and what you
want them to believe rather than just destroy everything, leave
them in tatters, own them in the public marketplace of ideas,
and then they have to go back to the drawing board. And where's
their drawing board? They're going to go back to the [__]
Discord server with its 20%, 40%, you know, conservative, and
60%, you know,
So, you want me to ask? >> Um, hang on, Aaron. I'm I'm
going to send you a clip of this guy to So, >> is it Matan?
>> We can actually show it on screen. But, um, I I do want
to like I want to ask you want me to you want an open-ended question.
You don't want me to to do leading questions
and you want me to get him to expound more? >> I'll definitely
do leading questions. I think that's okay. >> You want
You want me to expound?
>> You go. But what what I'm what I'm sorry, thanks. What
what I'm suggesting is that you you already know when someone
says you you've won this debate a million times. You don't >> I
don't I really don't know that I agree with Smug Bug on terms
in terms of like I need examples of what he's saying that you
build positively on top of what they're thinking. Like I I think
I would want an example like go with the Epstein files. Explain
to me how you would talk to a Trumper about the Epstein files,
right? I I really wish that we would get that example. Yeah,
Pisco could I think in terms of streaming both Aaron and Pisco
right now, what I'm looking for is somebody to go, "Hey, Smug,
because I can I can understand what he's saying like in a in
an abstract way, but I I just wish you'd go, "Hey, why don't
you Epstein files? You're trying to convince a Trumper that they're
totally hypocritical in the Epstein files. Explain to me using
your framework instead of calling them an idiot or a loser or
somebody who doesn't believe in anything, somebody who doesn't
care about kids. Why don't you show me how you'd argue that?"
Cuz I think it'd be something like, "Wait, don't you like need
to get rid of this guy? Isn't he like actually protecting?
Why why isn't he like why would you know Biden have been protecting
but Trump isn't something like along those lines? Maybe maybe
that's more to prove to anyone that you're like you're smarter
than them on the constitution, right? Like everyone knows that.
But what I think is valuable is you can use that knowledge to
figure out what does this person actually believe that they are
describing through I support the constitution, right? like what
you're trying to find their actual values and then give them
something that's more compatible with their value set than what
they're claiming. Now in the short term it might feel like well
am I not just helping make their conservative worldview more
sophisticated and nuanced and whatever and you know kind of almost
giving them tools to be more effective and I would answer yes
but those are also the very same tools you need to understand
that your worldview isn't actually compatible with your value
set and will help you move away. I think that because all of
the conflict between the right-wing and the left and we've seen
years of like debate culture now online hasn't really changed
very much other than cement everyone's positions and kind of
destroy discourses like the ability to have meaningful discourse.
It's just performance and you know you can't even capture much
of anyone's audience anymore. I think that that is more valuable
as helping people understand their value sets in the context
of like a better ideological framework which in your case would
be liberalism or or whatever you would name your ideology right.
It would be helping to get people towards your side of the aisle
by giving them the tools they need to better understand their
own value >> I I I think I'm I'm trying to understand.
Um let's let's apply it in practice in this example. So uh straight
away can can you play this with volume on it actually? Oh, go
for it. Oh, I don't hear anything. I don't know if you guys hear
anything. >> Yeah, I'm not getting any audio. Nope. >> Wait,
I
>> She's a hack. She's a hack fraud. Nope. >> No.
Pause. Pause. Pause. Okay. I think Yeah, that's exactly what
I'm looking for. Pisco just did it exactly right. I want you
to run through this with a real example so I can understand exactly
what you're saying. Go. Now he found it. Found the precise example.
We're going to actually get Smug Bugs.
>> We should follow it. That's what I'm being American
means. We should follow >> then the Biden administration
shouldn't
>> What about
So should we follow the Constitution or not, sir?
>> Okay. So if the constitution So so so you just said
he just said we should follow the constitution. If the constitution
says that these people do get due process rights, should we follow
that? So the constitution? >> Yes or no?
>> No. So you don't think we should follow the constitution
when you decide?
>> is there any part in this clip where Tim is not like
trying to get a word in and can't at all? He said we should follow
the constitution and then
>> thing I asked him >> it's like a cleric in age
of empires. >> I said if it says that these people should
get rights under the constitution should be followed. He says
no. So it's >> and so let me let me let me interject here.
Listen I want due process for everybody. I want constitutional
rights where they apply. I am I am scared and confused right
now because
situation with immigr >> this is this is not untrue. read.
This is not untrue. People do just want to be understood, be
heard, right? That is absolutely true.
But I don't know. Like there has to be a way to point out that
like they're also just people who shouldn't be trusted or shouldn't
be like really listened to, right? Like you don't actually believe
in the things you think. You're kind of like just totally unreliable.
Like you're you're basically like a baby. You're like a baby
who's crying for a bottle and and but you're trying to convince
me that you have like some idea of what you're talking about.
But really, you're just crying for a bottle right now. So, I
don't have the milk for you, but I'm just pointing out that you
you are a baby crying for a bottle. You don't know what you want
>> to be crying cuz you kind of feel >> Democrats.
I don't know what to do. >> That's the electorate. That
is the electorate. You're not wrong. You're not wrong. But that's
not what Pisco does, right? Like Smug's trying to get Pisco to
be somebody else. There isn't really somebody like this right
now. >> I don't think I don't think there's anybody like
this, right, who actually goes and and has like meaningful conversations
with people and changes their minds. I don't think there's a
single person like that. Pisco is not that guy. I don't know.
I don't know if Pisco wants Maybe he wants to be that guy. Be
cool if that guy existed. >> Shackled to a system that
will kill our country. I say I don't know that anyone will accept
that. >> The enemy is within. The people who are destroying
this country. The people who are destroying this country are
the bootlicking shills. The bootlicking shills who just trust
the government. Who just trust the government. Listen, we have
a constitution. >> So, we should pause it right there.
So, help me out with that specific clip cuz I like that clip.
I think it shows like what I care about. Keep in mind that while
I'm saying all this that people are yelling at me from you can't
really hear right now. Yeah. But talk to me through it. >> Yeah.
Well, I'm not going to underestimate how >> uh Oh, do I
have my social stream
>> Yeah, Red. This is honestly why I like uh Josiah in
terms of conversations, right? I think the way Josiah does conversations
is the most effective way to do conversations with people. I
think that I didn't take Josiah seriously when he would just
come on and be like CNN and then at some point he like tapped
into sort of who he was a little bit more and decided to have
more like less contentious conversations, ask questions instead
of just telling people why they're wrong. And I think I think
that's like the most effective way to do it, right? I think that's
the most effective way to do it. I think there's something there.
I think that could be very very good. But in terms of like debate,
in terms of like I'm going to own you in the marketplace of ideas,
Pisco is very good at that, right? And that's like the brand
he's building. Maybe maybe he wants to be more like Josiah. Maybe
he wants to be more that guy. I just have never seen it. So how
how well you performed particularly in a like hostile real world
space like Yeah, for for sure. I mean on the one hand you made
this mentally ill guy look very stupid which is you know great
I guess for your for like the ingroup signaling side. He's clearly
he's clearly not okay. But I think I honestly I don't know. I
watch that and I'm like kind of 50/50 because I and this is because
I'm not, you know, like I think if Dude, I don't know, man. Is
is that not what like politics is in the modern day? You find
the most person on the other side and you amplify them as much
as possible. I feel like that's what modern politics is at this
point. Hey, I'm going to make the dumbest people on your side
as loud as I possibly can. I'm going to laugh at them. I'm going
to point at them. I don't have any real ideology, but look how
stupid those people are. Yeah. Yeah. I'm a total I'm a total
[__] But like look at how dumb those people are,
dude. Those Hey, I may be, but at least I'm not those people.
That's like how all politics work. >> If I was a liberal,
I'd be like, >> by the way, totally hate that. Totally
hate that fact.
Killed it. Like I I'm looking at this and I'm like, well, Tim
P doesn't make the worst case, which is that if you're shackled
to a constitution that is no longer serving the people, even
if you support it, like I I feel like you would make similar
arguments in favor of like against originalists, right? In favor
of amendments to the constitution. Like why is America, you know,
like tied to this document that Sorry, I need to stop highlighting
chat quite as much. I'm going to slow down with that a little
bit. Amplification destruction is is a special version of straw
manning that needs to be its owned category. I was this a pun
second. It's owned category.
Owned category.
It needs to be studied. Yes, exactly. It was was written hundreds
of years ago and is not necessarily fit for purpose in all aspects
and and I and I understand was intended to be modified regularly.
Like this is you're getting the merits of taking original. >> I'm
sorry, but I hear you're taking an actual merits position here.
I'm I'm kind of asking like you know assume as given oh sorry
that you know I do care about the constitution and its amendment
procedures right so I'm not opposed to amending the constitution
and and maybe that's what what needs to happen the question is
like do we respect it at the moment while it's in force uh but
that's kind of a merits discussion I'm like >> how
you know how you would approach this differently without without
changing my position yeah >> 100% what I would do is I
would immediately wedge Tim and that guest right I would make
Tim attack that guest cuz Tim has just given a different take
to the guest. The guest is not hasn't really thought about it
all that >> Pisco does that a lot. I've seen Pisco do that
explicitly in Tim segments, right? Where he's like, "Oh, you
guys just disagreed. Where do you why do you disagree on this?"
>> And it's just hardline proconstitution except where
it does things he doesn't like. Tim, on the other hand, is talking
about being more flexible. We're shackled to this thing that's
holding us back. So force Tim to come into conflict with the
guest. You address Tim and you say, "Well, hold on. You don't
agree with him. You're saying that you want something that's
more flexible." so that you can do the things you need to do
in this country in order to make it better. And he's saying we
should just stick to the Constitution and not think about anything
else. So which is it, Tim? Which one do you care about? >> Well,
I I definitely tried to do that in in this debate. I I >> got
33 subs right now. Second, thank >> And especially in the
first debate, I I tried to play him off his other guest. I mean,
you you saw that right there. >> Good job there. Actually,
I did see it. Yeah. I thought that those are the best moments
is when you wedge the Conservatives against each other, which
I think is is good. They're big tent which makes them vulnerable
to wedging. >> Yeah. So >> they're less big tent.
>> There's a comment in the chat right now which I'm I'm
curious what your your thoughts are. So like the Medi Hassan
approach which is just to like >> to crush everyone or
to try to crush
>> and just be yourself all the time and just uh uh be
ruthless.
What's wrong? Why is that not the approach that I should take?
Why why should I try to be anything other than completely ruthless
in all moments? The answer is going to be that while that is
effective for building an audience and it gets people on your
side, it also leaves you like if you're totally ruthless in these
moments, you have no humanity. People don't really care if you
get straw manned or actually completely misrepresented, right?
Like you could be treated anyway if you're going to be like without
humanity talking to other people, right? Probably even if you
have humanity talking to other people, you're probably still
it's politics. They'll probably still not care even if you get
misrepresented. But you get a few people who will stick around
and like kind of take your side on things, right? So, the idea
would be, okay, you don't you're not quite as ruthless. You have
actual conversations. People are willing to hear you out, right?
If you're just totally ruthless from the beginning, they can
write you off early. They can they can not take you seriously
for whatever reason, and you'll never change any minds. You might
win a bunch of people over. You might win a whole bunch of audience
over, right? You might make a bunch of money. You might be really
successful, but you you might never actually change any minds.
You might not make like meaningful positive change. Um, Red 473,
I think, in that in that Tim Pool appearance. It looks like that
for the first 40 minutes, but I don't think Pisco has to engage
in those, right? He could easily just engage with people who
want to engage more seriously. Like there are tons of people
who want to engage with him seriously. So, I think he he could
just restrict it to those people if he wants to. Just depends.
It's really about what he wants, right? Like the the whole point
of this conversation shouldn't be here's how you talk to right-wingers.
It's what's your goal? What's the goal with Pisco's Hour? What
do you want to do? What change do you want to see in the world?
Do you want to see a change in the world? Do you just want to
build a big channel? Because like realistically just owning is
like the best way to build a big channel probably. It's just
showing that other people. It's totally like critical engagement.
Totally. It's not positive constructive engagement, right? I
think the thing I like about Pisco's channel is he does the owning,
but there is the positive like uh what do you call it? It's not
just destructive. It's constructive problem solving, right? He
will say this is what I think should happen. He'll do all the
research on the stuff. He'll say this is the the policy I support.
Here's the constructive way to approach it. Right? I think that's
what I like about Pisco stuff. I don't see that from other people
as much. I think he does a good job of splitting with um with
constructive and deconstructive because I think that that wait
I think he does a good job. Sorry, it's the in this debate he's
like not doing he's not doing as much of the constructive. I'm
trying to say that I think he does the constructive stuff but
he also does the owning thing and and it's like makes it a little
better for me that he has the constructive positions built but
he could try to win people over too if that's what he wants to
do. If he wants to win people over if that's like his primary
goal. I do think the tack he takes is a little too aggressive.
I don't know if he operates in a different way though >> has
I I think I think we're seeing one of the end stages or rather
I think that ruthlessness that sort of debate discourse first
of all exist a liberal frame right liberalism allows for one
of the good things about liberalism is that like it allows for
this sort of discourse of ideas that come into contact with each
other essentially we use some vague uh approximation of market
forces to determine what ideas are valuable based on them kind
of meeting each other in ideological combat and then we decide
Thank you for the five gifted.
Oh, from his chat. Wait, did he come here and like find out people
who would like who would call him a lunatic and huh that's funny.
Thank you very much for the five gifted. I think that's another
hour on the stream. Let me check the best thing and then we institute
the you know the the ideal whatever thing that has come out of
that that forging of ideas, right? But we now live in a system,
particularly America, is in a system now where your main government
is very authoritarian, very right-wing, doesn't really hold very
many liberal values. The Democrat party has kind of collapsed
pretty significantly. And the kinds of people who are coming
up like Namani and like um and you know, sort of the the the
left that's been poised to try and start to influence the Democrat
party in the same way that MAGA influenced the Republican party.
They don't hold the same liberal values as the Liberal Party
either. So you're kind of appealing to now what I I I would argue
is probably the weakest proven weakest segment of American politics.
The far right is winning. The far left is doing better than it
has been for a while despite, you know, a lot of suppression
by both sides. And the Democrats are mostly spending their or
at least he's a max off mask off docer now. Yeah. Everybody in
that community is just a it's like Yeah, that is what that community
is. But don't worry, Red. You think you just said now?
It's been that for a long time. Okay. It has just been that for
a while now. Yeah, they're totally down with this. They've been
down with this for a long time. There was some plausible deniability
before. He's just like, "Oh, I I don't I don't bother with plausible
deniability anymore. All the people who are who expected enough
of him on a moral level are gone, right? So now he can just lean
into this. He doesn't have to be like a good person or even pretend
to be a good person. He can just be who he is." Democrat discourse
people as you've noticed are spending a lot of time attacking
communists rather than attacking the actual authoritarian right-wing
government that's in place currently. So like uh I think that
probably the ruthlessness has not really helped with this. Like
it doesn't work in this modern framework and even then I think
it's probably part of what led to this modern framework because
it just meant that everyone became >> but it feels like
it feels like you're suggesting it feels like you're suggesting
I should just not care about it. I should not I should just not
care about the values that I have and that I should adopt a more
like um apathetic ideology
towards this rights liberal based framework that I have championed.
I mean it just sounds like what you're saying is abandon that.
Oh okay. No, I think if you I think sorry, okay, this is this
is maybe maybe this is the hard cell, but we you and me have
had this conversation before and I just said a similar thing,
>> which is I think that if you truly have those values
and you want them enacted in the world, yeah, you probably got
to be a bit more tactical about how you apply them. Like the
you don't have to signal boost that you are a specific kind of
liberal every time you have a conversation with someone. You
can appeal to them through their framework and get them towards
your liberal values without constantly saying, "I'm a liberal.
I'm a lawyer. I'm uh you know whatever like I'm I'm like a debate
guy like I I'm I'm ultra consistent. I think consistency is a
little bit of a trap. I think you can afford to you know be different
things to different people to kind of code switch between different
>> Medie Hassan's approach. >> Okay. So you think
Medi is doing a good >> Well, this is the thing. I think
that Medi did a great job in the Jubilee debate because that's
the only thing that you can do in that situation is I think I
think the most valuable thing that Medi did there was demonstrate
to a slightly wider slightly more mainstream population that
fascism is kind of a norm in America. It's a real thing to reckon
with. It's not been exaggerated and overblown by the left as
many people say. This is like the fascists are now in mainstream
discourse pretty regularly in a way that wasn't true even just
a few years ago. I think that's the most valuable thing that
Medasan did was all the looking at camera shock liberal shock
going well I guess he's fairly leftwing but you know the sort
of >> he's kind of saying the same that I am like like
I understand he he's way more polished than me he's better than
me in these context I I've I've always said that Medi even if
I find myself to be more consistent I think Medi the way he packages
it is way more compelling and and I look up to Medi in that in
that respect so totally agree there but at base right he's doing
the same thing that I'm trying to do which is to find contradictions
and flaws in in the way that people are reasoning it and to be
consistent. And when being when challenged, he is like trying
to apply some kind of consistent framework and explain why he's
not like for example he's not committed to certain positions
given a you know a starting set of assumptions. Um so help me
explain if you think that or first who do you think is doing
the best incarnation of what you're talking about? Whatever it
is that you're talking about. Um, >> oh god. I listen I
whatever name I'm about to put out, I want to be clear that I
don't think anyone's doing a great job. Honestly, and I hate
to say it cuz I disagree with so many of his positions. I do
Oh, who is he going to say? Who's really good at this? I think
Josiah is good at it, but Josiah doesn't do a ton of conversations
right now. Who's he going to say? Who's he going to say? I don't
think it's Fentes. No. Oh, is there like a populace dude who
does a good job of this? Maybe somebody like Rogan. Maybe somebody
like Theo Vaughn, maybe somebody like this. You >> think
Hassan being good-looking and fashionable and forcing leftwing
discourse into the mainstream and making it so that you need
to know his talking points in order to date cute girls in America
in leftist places like it's he's just a bit >> this is
taking a really weird turn now for like you know leftist
>> I think he's an idiot. He has terrible values. I'm not
saying you should become hot. I'm saying >> they got a
whole medication for it now. Pisco, you got it. But I believe
in you. >> Although you are hot, but I'm not I'm not saying
you should become hot. Okay, I will simp. I What I am saying
is that Medi Hassan is amazing. And if you can perform Medihassan,
that's incredible. But not every environment requires Medi Hassan,
right? Some environments require a softer touch. I think that
what you could have done in that Tim debate that I'm talking
about was probably
to I I think wedge them against each other. I think you missed
an opportunity. One of the one of the big things that I noticed
was with Alex Stein. Like I I with my limited view of the debates
sphere, I know Alex Stein to be a completely insane evil idiot
duration. >> He's actually really really nice behind the
scenes. I'm just being honest. Behind the scenes, he's really
really nice. But I'm just telling you my interactions. I think
that he's a bad >> I didn't think I didn't think Alex Stein
tried to [__] with Pisco like that directly. Didn't
seem that way. >> When he's not harassing AOC
capital, he's a decent dude. I unironically think back when I
cared a bit more about the debate sphere and I was watching Hassan
and Vos and Destiny and the Twitch panels and I was on the Twitch
panels. Um like back back then I would I would see Alex Stein
and I would think this is a guy who knows his [__]
and is performing very very well and is doing exactly what he
needs to do in every >> Bro, how do they keep Doobie banned
from their Discord? This guy just throws money like it's nothing.
He's just throwing he's just throwing bills all day. Bills, bills,
bills moment. like I I consider him to be really really skilled.
He's very clearly performing. Um and I think that I think that
what is interesting is that he was almost able to steal some
of your like liberal aura because he started agreeing with you,
but by the point he agreed with you, you were already in such
a combat with a lot of the other people that I don't think you
noticed that Alex Stein was kind of available to build an allyship
with. And so he almost started taking talking points out of your
mouth and framing very reasonable liberal ideas as his ideas
which I think that's a good should be more like Alex Stein. >> No
but that's a good observation but but Alex sign is using me to
sound reasonable to him but I I don't know how I do that in reverse
and and also I there was a good comment here from Dubbie a super
chat where he's like Hassan doesn't go into enemy territory.
Hassan like I he gets >> okay but he that's what I mean
like he gets people who um to Dub's point are on the fence and
he's definitely like a better at just like having a chill conversation
than me like I am very I can be very unchill so yeah for sure
he has some social skills that maybe I don't have even though
but like all I'm just trying to say is >> it's a different
kind of thing right >> I'm not going to go and model myself
off of Hassan when I go into these spaces because Hassan >> doesn't
do that right like he has some >> go into these spaces
you can't model off of something that doesn't exist yet, >> But
but yeah, I agree. I totally agree. But what you asked me who
I think is doing it well. And when when you said doing it well,
I didn't mean like I guess I guess you meant like is like a very
good debate guy. But what I'm saying is that the debate guy format
doesn't work in the same way anymore. Not only has like liberalism
kind of lost its hold on the mainstream in America. I it totally
works. You just can't do the debate guy thing with people who
don't want to debate, right? With people who are only going to
mock. That's the only difference here. You just pick people who
are also in the same lane. It's like it's like, dude, you're
like an Olympic fencer, okay? You you fence in the Olympics and
then you show up to somebody and it's like it's like a a street
fight with baseball bats. It's like guess what? You're not going
to be that effective there. You're just not. It's just absolutely
not happening. It's come on, man. What are we do? What why are
we pretending these are the same thing? Why are we pretending
that you could like map tactics or use the same tactics in both
places? You can't. It's obvious you can. So you're just going
to have to do things that appeal to the to the far left and MAGA
or just just only appeal to liberals. A >> is Hassan debating
Charlie Kirk right now cuz that could be content. Let's go.
>> What it seems like a you know shrinking center uh as
everyone kind of gets pulled to the extremes. I think that you're
probably better off doing things in the reason I brought up Hassan
is because he's like he's very good at being a cultural force.
like he genuinely has pushed a lot of people to leftism, but
unfortunately he lacks a lot of like procedural understanding.
He doesn't think through his policies, prescriptions all that
much. Like he would benefit from people who are able to like
help him understand like the procedural process stuff, the the
legal stuff, the stuff that you're good at, right? So the
you think this chick melts Pisco's brain? I think he shouldn't
be allowed around her before a big debate. Okay,
it's not a I just want to say it seems like, you know, Destiny
started actively brigading this community and they became significantly
more misogynist in like 2 seconds. Like like just Destiny started
linking, you know, his YouTube, his Reddit, all of this, right?
Started tweeting about his Discord and suddenly this community
became really misogynistic out of nowhere. It's very
But we lack this sort of like mix between a liberal understanding
of governance and existing systems and the sort of leftwing push
that I think is probably going to end up being hopefully the
next populist movement cuz I don't I'm not that confident that
liberals can beat I know I know but I don't think I'm not that
confident that liberals can beat MAGA without basically incorporating
a younger more populist more leftwing movement under its banner.
To appeal to you I would say of course we will lick your boots.
Uh, don't worry. We'll do whatever. We'll do
>> We'll be loyal to the world.
>> We'll just help you get into power. >> I just
want to address I just want to address him. So, like So, first
of all, no, I get it. >> I I understand that there's a
version of me that maybe is like, you know, more congenial, more
I don't know, more chill, more like understanding that kind of
stuff. >> But have you ever seen The Wire? >> Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
I'm going to get the reference, but >> Okay. Avon Barkell
is talking to Stringerbell and Avon Barkell is like, "Yeah, I
guess I'm, you know, you're a businessman. I guess I'm just a
gangster, I suppose, right?" Like, and I want my corners. Like,
I just am like, I feel like my value ad isn't just an understanding
of like the systems of American government, but it also is to
do these kinds of debates. And I don't know if I am that kind
of person. Like, I like how do I how do you change me? >> And
I and it's a little vague still in my head. You just want me
to listen more. You want me to listen more to what people are
saying and and try to come from a more positive approach? >> Yeah.
So, look, I used to be a debate pro pervert. I I was very much
in the same boat. So, I feel like I've changed in the last couple
years as well. Nice. Uh I think I think that I was I was definitely
that position as well. I think what changed is that like I stopped
listening to what people say and I started listening to what
people mean. When someone says they support the Constitution,
you you it's better to try and understand what they mean by that.
realize that everyone's language is not a shared language. Especially
today, you know, when a MAGA person says that they uh support
the constitution, that means something totally different in a
totally different context in totally different language than
when you mean it. But the problem is that the conflicts arise
when you have the institutional backing of no no this is the
American version of what constitution means and what supporting
it means. But they've already rejected that American institutionalism.
They've rejected the rejected the elitism. And so you're coming
to it with in this from this like dominant framework of well
look this is what everyone agrees the thing is but they're in
charge now the institutions are being ripped to shreds by these
guys in part because they I I get a little bit of this oh what's
up straight right I didn't even see you in chat sorry I'm like
listening to Smug Smug needs to do more breaking up less proilitizing
okay I get that he made a list I'm starting to notice this a
lot more people proilitize a lot and I just like you sort of
zone out if you proitize way too much. You just kind people kind
of zone out and they You zoned out because Smug was yapping.
Yeah. But when I say proilitize, it doesn't sound like I'm insulting
him as badly.
Don't respect them as a tool of >> He's completely correct
though. He's he's correct in some of the things. Yes. I just
think you you have to bring it up with examples, right? When
he when he tries to uh cuz Pisco asked for a solid example in
the clip and Smug, I don't believe actually gave a solid example
through the clip. He's like, "Oh, you should try to turn these
people against each other." Pisco's like, "Yeah, I did that on
a different panel." Smug's like, "Yeah, that was good." But he
didn't actually Yeah, he literally skipped it, right? He literally
he actually did skip giving concrete feedback on that. It's like
it's a totally different way of thinking about things. I don't
know. And even when he described turning them against each other
or pitting them against each other, that's not a constructive
thing either. So like his original thing he was talking about,
we haven't even gotten an example of it >> Definition and
analysis and >> And they love it. >> And so I think
and they love it. They they they love ripping straight because
they're mad that people like you
feel stupid for not knowing what the constitution means. And
and correct me if I'm wrong cuz I could definitely be wrong.
It sounds like you're saying I should give less of a about these
and like or there's a >> there's a way someone could interpret
you right now. It says give a less >> underneath it all.
Pisco
people think that like they've stopped thinking America's awesome.
They think America like kind of sucks and it's being like >> b
it's being like sold off for parts, right? And they think the
constitution is the thing that they got lied to about the the
promise of America. They were lied to about and this is how people
justify it. They think they've been like lied to. They think
you justify it through the laws, through the Constitution. And
when you use the Constitution, when they feel like when they
see it that way, it suddenly stops working, right? They don't
actually, they used to believe, they they probably got raised
on believing that like they're patriots and America's awesome.
And now they're like, "Well, America actually sucks. America
is a failed country according to Trump, right? It's failed country."
And I don't think that you can actually like You're trying to
convince me it's not like their lives feel worse. They've been
told they're worse. How do you tell them that their lives are
better or they're going to be better? Like that's the thing,
right? Trump's like, "Oh, here's the enemy that's taking your
lives away from you. Here's the enemy that's taking your money
away from you." And you there's a it's really difficult to try
to come back from that and say, "Actually, nobody's taking anything
away from you. You just need to get used to like the way it is."
It's tough, right? And we know that cuz also you can't do that
with like socialists either. Okay? It all all comes down to that
question. Are you proportionally to like how well the overall
country is doing? Are you doing as well as you would have in
another time? Right? I'm not saying that the country's GDP isn't
improving. I'm not saying that the country doesn't produce more
stuff or anything like that. Are you proportionally doing better
than somebody 15 years ago would be doing in your same position?
Probably not. Is that something you can solve? Possibly not even.
Okay. Possibly not even. But I don't know. There's the thing
with like liberals right now is they'll tell people that like
things are going great, everything's awesome. And it's like no,
it's it's not really like for the average person, for the person
who's like 100 IQ, the world's kind of scary. It's a pretty scary
place right now being from America even. I don't know if it's
scary. I don't know if it's more scary or less scary from other
people's points of views, but I think I think there's reason
to believe that the world could be a scary place for somebody
who's like doesn't really know a lot about much and and is just
trying to get by. I still a [__] about it. >> I
I bet I I'm I'm Listen, I'm not I'm not I'm not pulling
clearly doesn't give the Constitution, so keep that in mind.
>> Yeah, I don't give a [__] about the Constitution.
But um why should I listen to you? Because And now you will respond
and I'll give you plenty of time. Why the [__] should
I listen to you? You don't care about the I care about. you think
of the Constitution, you know, you wipe your act with it. And
you're telling me like basically to stop relying so much on uh
you know, so how do I know that you're not just trying to push
me to be more tanky communist and um abandon the principles that
I'm trying to defend? >> I am basically giving you tools
that I hope will eventually get you there. But the tools are
useful to you even if you don't, right? Like >> get me
where get me where. Get me to not care about >> the big
thing. That's the big thing that I don't know if Smug asked this,
right? Like what is the goal of Pisco's Hour? You have you have
some grand plan for Pisco Hour, right? You launch this YouTube
channel. It's doing really well. What is your ideal, you know,
what's your 6 months, 1 year, 3 years, 5 years, where are you?
Where are you going? Right? Where are you going, buddy? What
are you where you going? What are you doing? And that that informs
like what tools or tactics would be helpful to him. Just critiques
of his tactics broadly don't even work. If he just wants to like
absolutely like conversation people, then he's going in exactly
the right direction, right? Not even that harsh. I use that term,
but like if he just wants to have forceful conversations with
people where he embarrasses them and he's going to be the most
right all the time, then he's going in the right direction. And
I don't think like if if that's just his goal, if that's what
he really wants, then Smug's giving him tactics for like reaching
people. He doesn't care about reaching people, right? Why would
he why would he care about reaching people? He believes that,
and there's another way of approaching it. You just put what
you want out into the world and people will filter into you,
right? That's it's easy >> about the constitution of liberalism
>> to to to value liberal institutions a little bit less.
But I I'm not trying to push you on that right now. What I'm
saying is if you have a value set that you want to push out into
the world to to propagate uh and that those are liberal values.
I am giving you I feel I'm giving you tools that would help you
do that more effectively. And I also think that in enacting those
tools, what you'll probably realize is, oh, these people who
instead of instead of the instead of these destructive conversations
I'm having with people, which I enjoy. I love I I'm so sad that
we no longer live in a world where destructive conversations
aren't productive. I I I really enjoy. Destructive conversations
are literally never productive. They've never been productive.
That is a cope for somebody who used to engage in destructive
conversations and occasionally somebody would go, "Oh, I kind
of think you changed my mind on this." No, you did. No, they
didn't. No, they didn't. They never work. As soon as somebody's
defensive, you're not changing their mind with them. I >> You
ever hear the phrase? It's a very popular phrase, you never win
an argument. You can never win an argument, right? Everybody
knows that. Everybody knows that deep down that as soon as something
turns hostile, as soon as it turns into an argument, now you
can't win. There is no winning. I I >> what Smug Bug misses
is dog panels. Talked about that in my discord debate per they're
very fun. I I I get as much of them as you do. But I think unfortunately
the way forward is to have constructive conversations with them.
And I think once you hear why MAGA are antiax or why MAGA don't
believe in liberal constitu in the constitution or liberal institutions
why why they're okay with Trump being an authoritarian dictator
for 5 years like I think once you actually genuinely are able
to sympathize and understand and and have their messaging resonate
with you I think you will understand some of the failure points
in liberalism that will help you build a stronger liberalism
in the future that will help you cover for the things that they
they won dude they exploited your weaknesses. >> You're
not You're not doing I'm sorry. >> You're not doing me
any favors. >> You lost. You lost. You lost. You lost.
Hey, Pisco, you lost. Hey, Pisco. Pisco. Pisco, you lost. Pisco.
Pisco, you lost. >> The whole the whole
argument, I don't know if you've been around in the zeitgeist
right now, is that there are these commies trying to infiltrate
uh liberal spaces to make them less liberal. And you're >> Look
at that. >> And and you're and you're basically saying
reference
You're basically saying that, >> dude. Uh,
do we want to do like a little thing here? Dude, I I remembered
this this morning. Okay, I remembered this this morning.
And I I sent this whole point to some people, but it's like,
do you guys remember? Hold on, let me go find the time stamp
here. You guys remember this time stamp from the Pisco Destiny
video? >> Trying to jump it all, but the fact that Aaron
is just somehow like crept back at everything is that's just
wild to me. But I just >> So Pisco asks, "Why did you block
me on Twitter?" And Destiny says, "Oh, well, you know, the fact
that Aaron's back at everything, she crept back into everything."
Dude, I kind of forgot that Destiny was super defensive of Aaron
and liking his people right after the the stuff dropped, right?
So, like the implication is from a bunch of people. Wait, Destiny
Destiny hates Aaron. She gave away his text messages to President
Sunday. That wasn't what he said right off the bat. He uh what
what did he do? He like banned Aaron from his chat, right? Banned
Aaron from his chat. And these are like his things. Neither him,
talk about Lykan, nor Aaron have necessarily ever done anything
wrong to me directly. I'd vouch for them as far as that goes.
I don't think Aaron was even trying to be sneaky or anything
in this situation, but I just can't keep surrounding myself with
people who are in league with crazy dooders anymore. So, it's
like, oh, I don't want to be around you if you're around Sunday.
But it's like, oh, she's never done anything sneaky to me. I
don't think she was trying to be sneaky. I don't think they done
anything wrong to me directly. Right. Was this recent? Yeah,
it was recent. And then there was also this one. So, somebody
probably asks like I I guess I could look this up. I don't know
what the response is, right? Honestly, I just think she's just
friends with him, which is stupid all on its own. Ah, I keep
biting my tongue. But Aaron and Lyken, dude, I'm having a rough
time with basic human function today. But Aaron and Lykan are
probably two of the few people I've met that I would say would
never do any backstabby, sneaky, weird ever. I just think bad
judgment when it comes to friends/ Sunday lol. Like, sorry. I
just I hate to to bring that up out of nowhere, but it's just
like, yeah, people people make little catty references or not
catty references. People like try to say Destiny should hate
Aaron. Why Why would he hate Why did he just lie? Which of these
cases did he lie in? And why would he just lie? Or what changed?
I I don't know. I would love some answers to that, but probably
never get them. It's just whoever he's spiteful towards in any
given moment, everything changes, right? No consistency. Cool.
Cool, cool, cool. Back to this. I found Aaron through you. I
found Aaron through you. >> I understand. >> You
introduced me to Aaron. >> I know, but you're basically
saying that, yeah, part of that is true. >> Well, okay.
So, here's how you could think of it. You could look at it as,
look, these leftists have some We lost. These leftists might
have some useful tools in the same way that MAGA had some useful
tools for the Republicans. I'm a >> Oh, by the way, no
mentions of being a communist there at all. Nothing. No >> Liberal.
I'm better than these stupid conservatives. I think that we can
get the benefits of these leftists. We'll give them some concessions,
whatever. But I think we can get the benefits of their youth,
their vigor, their new ideas, their, you know, their their ideology.
We can extract and exploit that ideology in order to win the
next election with that sort of populist figure that the Democrats
have basically rejected for the last 15 years. That is clearly
what you need to be successful. So I yeah, I think you should
back people like Mandani. I also think you should be there to
help people when they run up against the realities. That that's
great. But I think that I think that you should be there to But
this is what I want. I want I want more mandanis. I want populists
who seem to be good operators, who aren't idiots, who aren't
going to >> Yeah. But if if mom Donnie did something that
that I view to be anti-constitutional or for example, let's say
that mom Donnie tried to collectivize
in violation of New York or federal law some like bodegas, right?
And it was more than just buying like the five the the pilot
program than he wants to do do. Let's say that mom donni started
like um trying to take more dictator dictatorial control over
New York City. I would call him out on that. And I think that
like my my support for Mani is conditional. It's conditional
on him upholding some >> I think your support should be
conditional. Yeah, >> I agree. Well, okay. But would you
be would you be against it if Mam Dani was proposing bills and
legislation that would allow him to do the collectivization he
wants and those go through the normal procedures? >> Would
I be against? Yeah, because I think it's it would be a bad idea.
But >> that's fine. That's fine. But do you see the difference?
Right. There's a distinction because in one of those situations,
you're just going to bite the bullet and go, "Well, I guess my
liberal democracy voted for something I don't like." And on the
other side, you're like, "I don't like you opposing my liberal
democratic institution." I I would be more concerned with the
him trying to >> to usurp the the rules of the >> usurper
usurper
the >> as opposed to >> implementing it um you know
legally although I would be against both. Um I'm curious Aaron
what's your reaction to this all because there are many different
kind of layers to what I'm hearing from Smug. Like on the one
hand I think um he's expressing a kind of general failure of
liberals over the past four years. a better counter to it than
Smug's hypothetical of like would you support Mandani going through
the Democratic channels to enact a fundamentally socialist or
like collectivist nationalized um industry type legislation or
whatever that you wouldn't support for other reasons but obviously
as far as it going through those channels you don't principally
oppose that you oppose it on a different basis I think the better
question is would you be okay with Democrats actively and over
overtly subverting the law in order to restore law and order
that Republicans have disrupted did uh ever since the second
Trump term has
>> See, and I think that that's like weak because you're
kind of playing like like there are there are levels to this,
but I do think that, you know, you're playing by an honor system
with people that are proving to be dishonorable. So, at what
point do you kind of stop having one hand tied behind your back
and you start fighting back not because you want to centralize
in a mass power, but you're actually trying to take it away from
those that are abusing it. >> So, I'll answer that. So
I'm not saying that we should play completely honorably in that
sense. For example, I'm in favor of like based gerrymander plays.
I'm in favor of expanding the core.
I'm in favor of getting rid of the filibuster to suit Democrats.
I'm in favor of a bunch of what what people would consider quote
unquote playing dirty. I'm in favor of getting rid of the electoral
college. So, but I view those all as like being legal constitutional
things that are in keeping with the principles and just there's
some norms that have already been broken by Republicans that
I think that you know Democrats need to um need to fight fire
with fire.
>> sorry, norms. So, for example, >> in keeping with
keeping with the principles and norms, who's whose principles
and norms? >> I'm saying that there were violations of
norms. For example, when the Republicans did these crazy jerrymanders
of Wisconsin or when they uh denied hearings for Merrick Garland
for Supreme Court or when they're playing around with the filibuster
and making carveouts when it suits them that the >> Would
you have would you have supported Obama just appointing Merrick
Garland and telling him get on the court? Yes, >> because
there were constitutional arguments for that. >> Yes, I
would. >> Okay. See? Okay. Nothing like that. No, no, but
but that is something where I think that there's a there is a
constitutional argument for that and it's um waiver a legal principle
of waiver where um I would be >> wait but but what would
I think the issue there would probably be I think I think Trump
didn't Trump float the waiver thing as well and
I I can't imagine Piscll would have been behind >> favor
of it. If I if he did something that I took to be illegal, unconstitutional,
I would not support it, right? I did not support Joe Biden closing
down the border with in in contravention, I think, of the Immigration
Nationality Act. I wouldn't support um collect illegal collectivization.
I wouldn't support um you know, Biden
trying to do a coup of Trump after Trump won the election under
the rules and regulations. So yeah, I would support things that
I consider like based and strong and like uh maybe even potentially
radical for Democrats to do, but not if it violates some kind
of uh fundamental principle of of uh constitutional order or
or legality, you >> Okay, but those those principles those
fundamentals can Sorry, Erin, go ahead. >> Uh would you
be okay with the future Democratic administration prosecuting
Trump in violation of the Scotas ruling on presidential immunity?
like >> prosecuting him on things that are clearly within
>> I had a lot of thoughts going on right now that I'm
not quite there's just some some interesting things going on
here. I think I think it would be like productive almost for
me to like have a 60-second timer for myself where it's like
if I'm if I'm literally going 60 seconds without some kind of
like dynamic feedback from an audience of some kind, I need to
pause and like query the audience, pull them back in with like
asking like a like a rhetorical question or just any question,
right? I think I think the idea of like I wonder if as an entertainer
you should have any real response that's like longer than 60
seconds with no especially if it's collaborative like this like
60 seconds something like this right something like I I don't
know the exact time I don't know what the exact length is but
I find that like this was pointed out to me today that like sometimes
someone like Pisco or someone like Smug Bug actually Smug Bug
does it as much if you if you just yap for like more than 60
seconds with no feedback you're just like in your own head talking
talking
that can be good. You might even be really entertaining. I think
man I think Fuentes does this naturally.
I think that's why he is such a good speaker. Hate to hate to
hate to use him as an example but he'll constantly pause and
go and why do you think that is? Why do you think they do that?
Right? Why do you think they do that? So you talk you talk. You
talk you talk and then you ask a question to make somebody like
engage and come out of the trance a little bit. Right? So, like
if you're just talking talking and you're just saying why I believe
this, why I believe this, why I believe this. Example, example
example example example. You're monologuing, yes, but it's not
like good monologuing. It's not monologuing that makes anybody
think. It makes people like kind of tune out and then eventually
they just like close your stream without engaging, right?
And I'm like starting to see it now, the points where
I wonder if I should just um I wonder if there's something to
this. I've just never really I haven't thought about it from
that perspective. Like obviously everybody thinks about it in
terms of like oh you're yapping like somebody's just yapping
right now and I I don't really like this. It's like whatever
kind of boring. Um
I think there's just a good way of like when you when you form
your thoughts you should be forming your thoughts in terms of
I want to ask this question. This is the question that I think
the audience most wants answered and like approaching it from
that way or approaching it from like that direction. I don't
know. Yeah. I just I somebody pointed this out to me today and
it's just like oh this is actually
like a good way of of handling things. Are you saying Pisco is
doing that? I'm saying Pisco can do that. Um, everybody can do
that, right? I'm thinking that's sort of something that elevates
the best speakers above other people. That's something that Fentes
does. I know for a fact he does all the time. Like he because
he monologues so much that he does he constantly asks questions,
right? Can you guys think of like anybody who does that better?
I'm trying to think of somebody who does it better than Fuentes
off the top of my head who's like re-engaging the audience constantly.
But that's cuz Fuentes, I believe Fuentes basically doesn't look
at his chat while he's live. He just does like a broadcast. He
could be in a totally silent room just doing his broadcast by
himself, right? Chud Chud does it pretty well. Yeah, Chud's a
good example. Yeah, Chud would be a good example.
Um, but I don't know if he's asking questions. He's like breaking
it up with jokes. He's breaking it up with different stuff. Yeah,
Chud is pretty good. Trying to think of it like in terms of,
you know, sometimes I think of streaming as like I'm looking
for things to criticize, right? And
maybe that's a better a better lens or or another lens you could
apply is like how what questions do I want answered. I think
I do that sometimes too though. I don't know. Trying to think
more about process and stuff right now and how to make how to
make the content better on stream. Um co-host one way to do it
for sure. Tucker just praised him for that saying is yeah but
it's it's uh so I think he does it naturally straight. I know.
Um it is really good and it is that he's in the quiet room. I'm
even pulling some of Tucker's uh stuff there to inform what I'm
saying, but I'm saying he he engages the audience, right? He
he re-engages them constantly with like a it's like he's like
the embodiment of of just asking questions sometimes, right?
But he will be it's like a lot of and why do you think that is?
Why do you think they do that? Why do you think he said that
exact thing? Well, I'll tell you why. Right? It's a lot of re-engaging
you to keep thinking about the stuff I'm talking about. Don't
go into a trance. Don't go into a trance. Don't go into a trance.
And I'm wondering how you would go about I wonder if there's
like ways of doing that technically that you can you can in your
own head like get into doing it like how do I train myself to
do that without um socratic? I don't think so. Asmin does it.
He tees up rage bait for his audience and then he pits everyone
against each other. Yeah, I'm trying to think. There's somebody
Riyle gave me like um Riyle gave me links to somebody he thought
was like doing really well right now. And I wonder if I should
check out one of those videos. It's like a right-winger that's
kind of but apparently he's doing like pretty good videos right
now. A lot of different um who is this guy? This is a video.
I'll go see if I can find a different one of his videos. One
that's not uncont.
This is on a Destiny. The Destiny um
the >> I think I said this in the past with like 60% conviction.
I said 90% >> effective. I wonder if this guy would be
doing some of the same thing. Muddy Hassan versus two gropers.
>> So fellas, we got the >> Oh well, maybe. Sorry.
All right. I thought this be I thought this would be somebody
with a camera. How do you listen to somebody who's just like
a little PNG tuber in the little corner there? How do you listen
to that all day? How do you even trust that that person knows
what they're talking about? I'm probably sub to him, maybe. Anyway,
sorry. We should we can continue on with the content. I'm I'm
like thinking of a lot of this stuff right now for different
reasons. It's like sort of meta on on how to make it more engaging
over time cuz sometimes I'm like watching it's like not super
engaging to me. So, probably there's like a good way to do this.
Um,
preface cam Perry streams are just better. Okay, there's probably
a good way to do it with content where they're not doing it themselves,
right? That might be something to work on. I think this conversation
could be a good good one to dive into and just figure out how
I want to approach that. Uh, cuz you can do it through like obviously
it naturally happens when you have a co-host, right, who wants
to cut in that if you're if you're doing collaborative thing
with a co-host, they will pause you, they'll ask you questions.
It will like be a natural rapport back and
But also making sure you can do that, making sure you can gain
those benefits if you're doing it by yourself would be pretty
effective. Asmin Gold might be another really good person to
look at there. But I I need um I need a framework to like measure
this somehow. In my head, it's like how often do they ask like
rhetorical questions or questions of the audience at all? Um
it's like prompting your audience to break out of the the trance,
right? Prompt the audience consistently to break themselves out
of the trance. How how do people get away with this? I don't
know. This the it's a way been talking for more than 60 seconds.
I know I've been talking for more than 60 seconds. Spruce Willis,
but I've also been engaging and asking questions.
You're mean to co-host though.
Probably. Let's see. It's probably a lot of watching my own [__]
too. Anyway, that's that's my own little, you know, thinking
of myself, thinking with the audience, trying to get your guys'
input on it. I I don't mind like I think people get have good
input from the audience, even if they're not streamers themselves
in this case. I think it could be quite effective. Anyway, we're
back to Smug and Pisco talking through how to talk to right-wingers
>> within his core executive authorities. >> I don't
know. I >> covered by the immunity. Right. Right. Would
I be against prosecuting Trump for things that are that are clearly
>> now carved out as exceptions within the immunity ruling
that previously wouldn't have been? >> Yes, I would be
against it. Um I I would not I would be in favor ultimately um
of having a court that would overturn that decision. Um, but
absent some non-trivial reason for overturning the law, I I think
that we should not prosecute Trump for things that are within
his core executive of power, we should just um try to work within
until there's a such time as that there's um Supreme Court majority
or a way to implement that kind of reform separately. Um but
as it currently stands, no, I would not be in favor of prosecuting
him for any other reason that it would be futile, right? It's
futile to prosecute him for things where the Supreme Court's
just going to say, you know, you're not allowed to do that. And
then obviously I wouldn't be in favor of violating uh you know
of just ignoring the Supreme Court. So >> ignoring the
Supreme Court. >> Yeah. So but but >> I think I think
this makes sense. But there's there is one important distinction
which is that like >> uh is Wolf Gand coming back? Probably
not with uh probably not. Um unfortunately I think that that
guy why would he open himself up to why would he open himself
up to being around me when apparently it's like a totally psychopathic
millionaire who wants to dox me or anyone around me like kind
of thing. going on, you know, why how how and why would he open
himself up to that? Seems >> like I I think I'm talking
about things that we can do in the real world and the, you know,
changing laws and and following the procedures required to get
to a state where you would be happy with that happening legally,
right? Whereas I think because America has gone so bogged down
in its like internal process and loopholes and trying to get
like basic stuff done procedurally I I I feel like a lot of these
conversations kind of end up being more about what we can do
under the current framework without changing the framework if
that makes sense. So like you know everything that you've said
is illegal is unconstitutional
could maybe this is just me lacking knowledge but like you could
make an amendment to like change a lot of the constitution. Oh
[__] Is uh Oh yeah, exactly. Top Bronson, this is
a big issue. But I just realized, wasn't the ice beside [__]
scavenger hunt today? I forgot about it. God damn it. Me two
>> To make something constitutional. Okay. So So any of
these unconstitutional things that you may not be a fan of today
could be things you would be okay with in the future if they
were amended. >> Yeah. For example, I I would be okay.
>> I would be okay with amending the Constitution to get
rid of this presidential immunity. I would be okay with amending
the constitution to yeah, you know, maybe to to give the New
York mayor some additional authorities in the context of the
New York Constitution. I might be okay with like, you know, amending
the Constitution to um allow
I don't know some some of these Democratic strats for with Oh,
god damn it. Uh I wasn't so I I was like yelling. No, no, no.
I was yelling, "I'm not muted. I'm not muted." But the mic actually
was muted. I didn't think I muted it when I walked away. I had
to go to my door. Um I had to pause because I wanted to talk
about this thing. Why? Why is saying he would be for certain
constitutional amendments? >> Does anybody know? Shouldn't
you Shouldn't you actually just be for every constit? Like literally,
if you have the votes to amend the constit
like requires a supermajority, right? It requires it might even
require more than that. There might be an actual level you have
to get to just for constitutional amendments. Why would you ever
be against
constitutional amendments? Like like shouldn't you just be principally
committed to like anything you can get the votes for to amend
the constitution with you would be like in support of? I I don't
even understand why he'd say like why would he say like oh you
know I'd support amending the constitution for this. I think
I think you should just say I yeah I'm totally down with amending
the Constitution. Something along those lines, right? Threearters.
Okay. In the Senate. Gotcha. >> Constitution. I might be
okay with like, you know, amending the Constitution to um allow
for
I don't know some some of these Democratic strats with respect
to the electoral college. Certainly getting rid of the electoral
college. I would be in favor of like even just a a signaling
constitutional amendment. This will never pass to be like, "Hey,
>> you don't support the Constitution
>> That's not true. Well, I mean, if you're willing to
amend it and then like I how how different is your position to
theirs, right? They want to change things. They say they support
the Constitution, but then they're but then they're willing to
change. >> Yeah. So, Smug's just coming through with the
exact thing I just said, right? Of like you shouldn't say, "Oh,
these are the things you're in favor of." You should say you
just are Yeah, you're down with any constitutional amendment,
right? Is he he it feels like he's saying the the same thing.
>> You don't support the Constitution
>> That's not true. Well, I mean, if you're willing to
amend it, then like I How different is your position to theirs,
right? They want to change things. They say they support the
Constitution. >> Oh, I see. >> No, no, no. You you
support the Constitution by supporting the the powers to amend
it as well. That's never mind. He's saying something stupid,
>> but then like he's saying he's saying that I think he's
trying to imitate a right-winger right now, right? That that's
probably what he's doing. He's trying to imitate a right-winger
instead of just Right. No, he's trying to imitate a right-winger
and saying, "Yeah, we all think you could change the constitution,
right?" Isn't that what we're saying? It's like, I just think
the bar should be a little lower, but you agree we could change
the constitution. It's not like it's not like set in stone, >> but
then they're willing to change things about it in order to get
>> they do it judicially and flagrant violation of the
processes. They don't use the legal channels and PCO is exclusively
talking about utilizing the powers that are vested within the
constitution that set out how you go about changing it in a democratic
way that does not subvert the law. Cuz like you said at the beginning
of this, you said that you were correct that like the constitution
has provisions within it where the the framers intended for it
to be amended and changed later, which is why they explicitly
explained how you how you do that explicitly explained. >> But
yeah, >> but this you have two minutes. Wrap it wrap it
up. Wrap it up. >> Okay. Okay. But this is why I think
that you kind of going attacking them from like an originalist
frame, right? The idea that they don't support the constitution
because they want to change >> Pottering politics donation
pisco Aaron. We mentioned Teamster/ Shan O'Brien. Barry Weiss
of the free press just interviewed him. He apparently spills
the tea on him and Trump. Him and the sob. Please react. This
just dropped. Check Discord DM.
>> The Constitution does like them talking. >> Why
don't you guys ever do that to suggest content? Why does nobody
ever just go, "Here's 20 bucks. Clever this. Be like Josiah,
guys. Be like Josiah." >> You know, immigration being a
problem. You don't have to change the rules of the Constitution
to deal with immigration. you have to change the constitution
to give them whatever powers they would want in order to deal
with immigration from their perspective. So it's not unconstitutional
to want the constitution to, you know, allow them power, you
know, increase power. >> Yeah. want to get rid if they
want to get rid of No, but it is against the Constitution to
say right now prior to I guess amending the due process clause
to make it not apply to um I don't know undocumented people which
I you know query whether that that would be a huge problem because
then you could just accuse someone of being undocumented and
thereby get like and all it would take is the government saying
you are undocumented and I guess you know then there's no due
process to see if you get due process. Well, so there's even
a problem conceptually in saying or potentially conceptually
in saying no due process for illegal immigrants if you need due
process to even find out whether you get due process. You get
me? So, um, but even but take that assumption, right? >> Yeah.
They're not advocating for passing an amendment to make a carveout
for due process for illegal immigrants. in favor of interpreting
the constitution either ignoring the due process clause or interpreting
the due process clause so as not to apply in this bizarre interpretation
that has not been um >> you see how a lot of normies >> see
that that way of speaking God I'm going to I'm going to start
critiquing things that I have like no actual basis to critique
okay speaks fine but I'm just saying like right there it's like
so they want to amend the due process clause but why do they
want to do that and how do they want to do that and why does
it like it literally doesn't make sense and here's here's how
it doesn't make sense and why don't they care because they don't
they aren't informed I don't know there's like a way to >> would
read you as caring more I was like really wordy in a way that
about proceduralism than caring about the actual things that
you materially change in the world right that's why I think they
end up a bit frustrated with you is because you say well that
would break the rules of the constitution that would break by
clause whatever B and they freak out and they're like well I
just want to fix the problems in my country why are you talking
to me about the video And also you're saying you're saying even
if you follow the rules you're still going to oppose it. So at
that point they're like well what the [__] going
to break the rules so I can change it if that's how it's going
to >> But hang on a second. So if there's a collectivization
initiative you know in general I guess it would depend like if
it's health insurance I'm fine with singlepayer. If it's healthcare
I I even you know don't necessarily I think there's a lot of
like market failures that make some of these industries fit for
collectivization or I don't know fit for government control or
whatever. And so I don't have a problem in principle with some
kind of >> Let's go. Pisco believes in it too. This is
always Yeah. >> Like government system that runs >> crown
corporations. Okay. State state enterprise. It's awesome. Bring
it back. >> But yeah, on the mer >> that's how you
make America great again. Okay. Through stateowned enterprise
>> of any policy. Sometimes I'll have both a substantive
and a procedural problem with it. The problem when when you guys
say things like you care more about proceduralism than the substance.
I I think with the proceduralism. >> Well, one is I think
it's easier to get people, you know, to agree with you on, you
know, following the law, right? Following the law. >> Liberals
to get liberals to agree with you, but liberals, >> that's
not true. I I don't think that's true at all. Think about how
liberals felt about the filibuster being invoked in the Senate,
right? Like, or sorry, nuking the filibuster. Think about how
liberals thought about that. It's like, technically, procedurally,
you can do that. It's just a norm. You can totally do it. It's
totally legal. they just hadn't done it before, right? People
don't like it when they don't get their way. That's ultimately
where it all comes down for uh from. But liberals have this a
couple of principles that make it easier to stomach when they
don't get their way. And like so they'll argue based on the rules
most of the time because they know the rules support the way
they think. The rules are basically the way that like America
is a liberal democracy. Of course, liberals want to follow the
rules, right? But ultimately if the rules in America,
how do I say it? cuz it's going to sound but obviously they lived
in a dictatorship they would be they wouldn't want the rules
to be followed right it's not like they're but I guess it's cuz
they believe in democracy anyway I live news now Jtock did you
hear I did not state interference in the insurance industry is
the reason we have an insurance crisis in California no that's
not state interference that's not stateowned enterprise that
is state the state setting a price ceiling a price ceiling is
not the same as a stateowned enterprise a price ceiling is economically
restricted completely economically am I not wrong on Isn't it
that you have price ceilings and so certain certain uh insurance
policies like can only go so high so they won't even cover certain
places? Like if they're like, "Yeah, in the next 5 years these
houses are burning down, then it's going to cost you an insane
amount to ensure them anyway." Um
>> people kind of just want to get their way and the best
way for a liberal to get their way is to argue the rules, right?
But everybody else is going to pound the table cuz the rules
don't support what they want >> thing anymore. >> Okay.
Okay. So you think that people don't care about following the
law? Maybe you're right about that. I don't know. uh usually
can't somebody who's pounding the table or or arguing from emotion
or arguing from like what they feel is just they're never going
to listen to you saying well the rules say I can rap you right
now. That's what the rules say. Okay. What's the Bill Bur joke?
Well, in the 1930s the law said I could beat you with a broom
handle. Well, there's something wrong with that obviously, right?
Talking about his girlfriend. Talking about >> his girlfriend
like George Bush wanted to pass an amendment to make sure that
there was not equal rights or like like that gay marriage would
>> law says I can beat you can beat you bloody with a broom
handle. That's what the law says >> become illegal, right?
He was considering a constitution amendment. My first gripe with
that would not be, hey, that's not there's like that would be
some bizarre interpretation where you think you could insert
that into the constitution. I would be like, well, no, even if
there's a constitutional way to do that. I don't want that to
happen. So, that's where I'm going to fight. >> They're
not mutually exclusive. They're mutually mutual. >> Not.
But I'm saying it speaks to your priorities if you began with
the >> Well, because that matters more to me, right? Sorry.
I'm sorry. does matter more to me because I think that what protects
our government from turning into something like Soviet Russia
or to turn into one of these um authoritarian
where where people's lives suck and where there's no respect
for freedoms and that kind of [__] So it's the structure.
It's this balance of power. It's this shared division of responsibility
between the government. You guys want to have a >> or what
I'm hearing is that you would prefer a unitary system where there
is no check on power or you know so >> no once you start
Once you once you start to carve away the democratically enacted
limitations on authority, what's the stopping point? Like I I
just don't trust these people >> Hold on hold on. Okay.
I sorry, but to be clear, I don't think either of us hold that
position. What we're saying is that you can understand, we're
begging you to or I'm begging you to understand why they hold
that position, why these liberal institutions have failed them
since the banking crisis, you know, the last 20 years. Like is
the middle class has been in decline. People have been feeling
like things are getting worse and worse and worse. No, are you
rolling your eyes? Okay, fine. I'm not going to >> wait.
Do you actually think the liberal system has failed people with
respect to like the Great Recession? The liberal system failed
us. And what in what sense? That's just a lie. That's a lie that's
told sometimes by these uh fake progressives or I should say
people who who wanted to, you know, burn it all down, but it's
not true. >> I don't want to burn it all down. I just But
I I think that what >> liberalism saved us in that context,
>> you know. So, so yeah, inequality is rough, but but
okay, liberalism saved us there. Like the Federal Reserve and
the >> So I get the argument from other people here will
be something emotionally it'll be something like >> liberalism
might like had might make it so like some rough parts, you know,
this global recession and you survive that. But realistically,
it it feels like everything's on a sharp downward decline. And
how do we stop that if we can't act radically? Liberalism will
always be about incrementalism more than anything else. we might
need radical change to save us from a major decline. And I feel
like that's coming, right? I I think that's generally >> our
liberal frame of government immediately enacted these these different
uh you know, TARP and um these different recovery acts in like
record time and the Federal Reserve
to prevent this from being a great great >> I agree. I
agree. I think they did everything necessary to prevent a depression
without requiring any consequences of the people responsible
for it. I think they probably should have bought major holdings
in those banks in exchange for that money. I think they should
have just nationalized the failed banks and kept people employed
and made those systems work better given that they clearly were
run very badly. >> Okay. But but when you say the liberal
system has failed these people, the liberal system has failed
these people. I'm just like I think that part of >> the
system that's that's failing to restrain Trump right in this
moment >> would nationalizing the banks in that case even
matter? I guess sorry this is 2008. would in the banks even I'm
trying to think of like why they wouldn't have had major holdings
in those banks. I feel like it was it was a loan, wasn't it?
Didn't the banks pay back the loan? Wasn't it wasn't the like
bailout wasn't that essentially like a loan that is eventually
was paid back? It wasn't just like forgiven debt, was it?
>> Should look at like actually what h what actually happened
there? Cuz I I actually don't know. So I don't know. I don't
even know like they they say it's like oh those banks just went
away. did did all that who there's no way they just paid it all
out is there >> ignore it left and right and it's only
as good >> maybe maybe they did >> as the enforcement
mechanisms and we're realizing oh a lot of this has come down
to it being contingent on the actors within it actually buying
into it >> if you didn't have these systems if you didn't
have courts it would be 10 trillion times worse the fact >> and
if I didn't have this stone that keeps away tigers I'd be getting
bowled right now it's it's kind of hard you laugh You you you
laugh, but but the the cogs in the machine that have >> I
had an oven in my stomach. I could bake bread in my tummy. Thanks,
smug
have slowed down Trump have been a great benefit to us. >> The
Fed bought that debt and put it in their own balance sheet. I
see >> Americans and we're grateful for them. We actually
are grateful that our courts, you know, even though Supreme Court
has been like horrendous. Even the Supreme Court has protected
us from just having concentration camps in Sakat for American
citizens and have put and people have listened to them and the
if we just had a system where like who cares if about like following
the procedure, following the law or whatever, Trump would your
lives would be much worse and we'd be in a much worse uh situation.
Yeah. So
instead of alligator Alcatraz
>> Yeah. Alligator Alcatraz is way better than I'm Yeah,
I agree. But it's bleak. It's just bleak. I know it's bleak,
but
>> it's true, >> man. I miss the alligator Alcatraz
discourse entirely.
I My understanding is there's like a bunch of tents in the middle
of the swamp and like the alligators just walk up and walk around
these tents and the inmates are in there and it's like holy like
it's just conditions alligators all over the place kind of worry.
Did Did anybody get mauled? Anybody get mauled by an alligator
at alligator Alcatraz? [__] was this to be modeled
for ICE staterun detention centers? The alligator Alcatraz? It's
really on the name. Whatever. Whatever. They'll watch a informative
video on it at some point. >> It could always be worse.
It could always be worse. >> It sounds like you don't you're
like it failed. Proceduralism has failed. Even calling it proceduralism.
>> God, this is >> there are gators around it as
in like like there is the the Oh, I guess it I guess it is the
ocean, right? It is the Pacific Ocean for actual Alcatraz, right?
It's a river. It's like a river that's coming out of going into
the ocean. It's like alligators prevent people from breaking
out essentially.
This is so hard. Sorry, you're right. But but this is hard because
what I'm trying to do is I'm trying to get you to understand
their worldview so that you can interact with it more effectively
in ways of the lefties or the mega right. No, I don't give it.
Don't I'm not talking to you about how to appeal to lefties.
There's a whole other >> No, I'm talking about actual Alcatraz,
bro. Yeah, I'm talking about actual Alcatraz in terms of in the
Bay or Yeah, whatever. Alcatraz had sharks. Yeah. >> And
this is not the conversation. I'm talking about MAGA, the right-wing,
the people who've given up on liberalism and are following Trump,
whether they're independents or libertarians or right-wing or
magma or whatever the Okay, like this group of people. These
people who don't believe in the things you believe in anymore,
who don't believe in the rule of law and justice and the constitution,
the things you care about, the proceduralism. They don't care
about any of that. I'm trying to help you appeal to those people
better cuz I would rather they were all liberals. That makes
my job easier. If they're all libs, that's way easier. >> I
So, I I don't have the secret sauce in how to appeal to MAGA.
I just don't, right? I I don't know that I'm the best person
to convince MAGA in the kind of like understand you. I think
you just don't want to. I think you got the secret source. I
think you can do it. I think you're able to I think you're able
to wedge them when you want to. I know. Dude, what do you think
this conversation is about? It's about making you not hated by
them. I think you're the guy. I think you can do it. I just think
that you don't you're unwilling to Don't shake your head. You
can do it. Stop Stop being Stop being koi. Okay. I think you
can do it. I can't even convince centrists who didn't vote for
Kamla that they did the wrong thing. >> The the reason
I think that it's worthy that Tallybots person is not a good
example. I don't know. People said I can't tell if it's uh what
do you call it? I can't tell if that Tallybots person was really
someone I maybe it was Connor said she was single issue Israel
and it's like yeah you're never going to convince that person.
Anybody who's like single issue you just don't worry about convincing
them like that those people you just leave them alone, right?
But I don't know. Pisco Pisco has empathy. I'm pretty sure Pisco
has empathy. He could even having this conversation with you
cuz I >> he could learn to he could learn to
>> use it in conversations >> 25% of the time and
then you ruin it the other 75% of the time. There are moments
in that simple debate where you're doing exactly what I would
want you to do the entire time and you get success. But the problem
is that success comes at a bit of a cost. I think Wait, is this
just Wait, did this actually reload? Yeah. Meowzilla Killer,
you tell me right now. Okay. So, you're just saying nobody has
the secret sauce? Literally, nobody. Cuz who's who's got the
the vision of America without talking about Trump?
Who's got that vision? I'm trying to figure out who's got that
I I haven't heard somebody who's got that vision who just talks
about their I don't know that there's room in politics for that.
The last guy who had a vision was
actually Bernie Sanders. And I don't even think the vision was
good, but at least it was a vision, right? At least it was a
vision. At least it was like, here's what I want. Here's what
I want, guys. I want I want billionaires not to be billionaires
anymore. I want I want the top onetenth of 1% to not own 90%
of the wealth you know to you holding to your values fast which
you can I think I think I just described two negative positions
by the way things he didn't want. Okay. I but I was just trying
to do the bill I was just trying to do the impression. So >> still
do you just don't need to perform that you're holding to your
values every second. Okay. You can perform that you're agreeing
with them momentarily in order to get them get the bigger prize
of pulling them over to liberalism. It's okay to build an allyship
with Alex Stein on the table if he is willing to concede to some
liberal values and you can wedge him against the more crazy guy
standing next to him or the bold guy on the other side of the
table. Like you can you can help these people towards a better
understanding. >> Did you ever watch me with uh with Destiny
debate people on Twitter? Did you ever watch that or hear? >> It's
literally honestly honestly it's the thing that most triggered
me into adopting this worldview I have today. It
>> it's unfortunately there's a big market for that and
I don't think it works at all. I think it's like been proven
not to work in terms of political effectiveness. If you just
want to do entertainment content, if that's all you want in the
world and that is at least what Destiny wants. I don't know about
Pisco. If all you want to do is be entertaining, right? be like
an entertaining bad person. That's fine. That's really easy.
Well, it's not easy, but it is very doable. It's very, very possible.
Watching you have seen it. I realized this doesn't work. You
made me realize this does not work. No, because I think that
you have the your read on that thing wrong. Like we would bring
in like these old grandmas and these other people and be super
nice and be and and be like, "Hey, so so what do you think about
this? What do you care about?" >> I can see the ones with
you. I mostly saw Destiny tell people that they were insane every
time that they >> Okay, he would get we would get frustrated
after a while, but but the truth like there were some
>> Sorry.
Yeah, we would get frustrated after a while, but come on, they're
>> where we started off super duper nice and just trying
to be like, "Okay, cop." >> Yeah. And and um and let me
tell you, some of these people, I'm not saying all of them are
unreachable, but it's kind of this whole thing where um like,
have you ever heard that like in order to >> to be cured
of your addiction, you have to like want to be cured? Like like
I almost can't reason you out of this position if you're if it's
if you've adopted it kind of as a >> Why would I want to
be cured by a smug prick? You're making it an additional emotional
cost for me to have to concede to you. >> Do you want to
be like Dr. K and do like therapy? I can't do therapy on stream.
I'm not I'm not good at it. I'm >> It's not therapy. It's
not therapy. I listen. Me and you, dude. We're the We're the
same. I'm a debate pervert. I want to cry. >> Why? Why
is Smug like borderline crying right now? Can you chill? Smug,
can you chill? Smug, what are you doing? >> People, it's
fun. It's really hard. I have values that I want to destroy people
over. I have to hold back and pull punches. I get it. But like,
man, I think that those Twitter conversations were literally
the thing that made me think they're the reason I called in the
first time is because they were so horrible to watch to realize
these two smug elitists who know who obviously know so much more
than everyone they're talking to. Like even when you baby people,
you you you you are like you are lured into this like need to
to to demonstrate that you do know more, the liberals know more,
that this is the better worldview, you should come join our side.
It's it's it's a product of the ruthless debate combat that happened,
right? The whole point of that, you look at the Vosch days or
whatever. Vosch's whole thing was having debates with making
them look like dumb, winning the power game, the status game,
and then pulling people over and converting them later. That
worked for a little while back then, and it doesn't work anymore.
It didn't really work back then. Trust me, those it it will work
the exact same way on the exact same demographic of people like
computer science first years. Those people, okay, or like like
high schoolers will love that. And they're totally like not setting
the world views at all. And those people are winnable, but those
people are still winnable. You just can't win them in your anymore
because they're all being won on Tik Tok and right. And there's
a whole Tik Tok debate culture where they they still fight for
these people in the same way. just a lot of people on in Twitch
politics aren't like competing in it at >> More. You can't
just bludgeon people and prove that this world for you means
you win more fights. >> Okay. So, send me send me a clip
send me a clip of of this kind of style that you want to cuz
um yeah, send me a clip of this and what you mean by it. Okay.
Because I maybe you have a point. I I'm just I would love to
see the empirics behind the convincing cuz I I'm black on the
following. I think the bullying might be more effective than
sharing and relating and being constructive. I I don't have a
reason to think. >> I think shame is good. >> I do
agree. But again, these all these tools all have their place.
That's my point. That's my point. These tools all have their
place. Like you can be mediasan some of the time. I think that
Tim, you know, Jubilee >> works way better when you mediasan.
I think I see you be mediasan in good situations, but the Timool
conversations was a time when you probably could have wedged
conservatives against each other by being the one good liberal.
you will get more of your liberal values out in the world by
being the one good liberal than you will I think like insisting
on maintaining you know like institutional consistency or you
know consistency with your institutional values.
Why are there two soap boxers in chat? Cuz they're two different
people. There's soap box and soap box society. They're very different
people. And these all things you can believe in >> be inconsistent.
I mean is your is your prescription be inconsistent or not? >> No.
Is Josiah inconsistent when he treats people like human beings,
which he's totally capable of doing? No, you don't have to be
inconsistent. You don't have to change any of your beliefs. You
just figure out how, man. Pretend you're talking to a child.
Like, actually, but like an actual child that you're trying not
to make them aware that they're I don't know. Pretend that your
girlfriend is watching you talk to like a and trying to explain
something to them. No, not your girlfriend. Pretend somebody
you're on a first date with is watching you interact with somebody
who is really dumb and you're trying to explain something to
them. And so you have a lot of patience, a lot of understanding.
You're you're trying to be a good person. You're trying not to
seem like an [__] who's just going to like try to
slap this [__] in the head. You know, that's what
you should be trying to do. Come on. >> Care about consistency.
>> You should No, no. You should you should care about
consistency for yourself, but not demand it in others. I I think
I think it's valuable to accept that most people are inconsistent.
How How do I debate someone? >> I just watched that statement
tie a knot in Pisco's brain. >> I just like >> Yeah.
Sorry. Sorry. I'm trying. >> It's hard for me to like all
my suspenders. I'm trying to be the lip whisperer. It's hard.
>> I don't know what it means to like like to have a debate
where I don't demand consistency of the person I'm talking to.
Like that just seems like we're just saying noises. We just noises
at each other. Like I don't know what it means to like >> he's
going to go down the whole line of if you want to be smug, if
you want to be the smug prick who like people hate, then at minimum
you should be intelligent enough to explain to somebody how they're
wrong and how like the consistency that they're trying to point
out in you or inconsistency is like somehow the same as them,
right? Like you you should demand consistency, but you should
do it in a way where it's like you're demanding consistency.
It's like do you see point out the discrepancies? Point out one
that they would feel, right? Hey, this person wants to go break
through into cities and like enforce some federal mandate, right?
It's like, okay, how would you like it if the federal government
could play could like tell you that, you know, your yard's too
big or something and they could come in and like decide they're
taking some of your land? Like, I don't know. Like, I'm trying
to think of how I'd do it exactly. Like, the federal government
coming over and in kind of infringing on your civil liberties
as a citizen. You don't like it. So, why do you why are you okay
with it with certain people? Why are you okay with it with non-residents
or sorry with residents permanent residents? Like you you have
to frame it in terms of their concerns about the world and how
they look at it. >> Okay. Okay. Go help me. >> Okay.
So So instead, >> but by the way, that is hard. It is very
hard to try to think of things that way. Um especially when you
are Pisco. Pisco has like obviously he's trained as a lawyer.
That's not how he should be like he should be arguing in a way
where he can prove things out, right? That's like his entire
framework. I don't know. I don't know if like the the good liberal
guy I don't know if that's who he should be who Pisco should
be. I'm not convinced of that. I think he could be funny. I think
he could be like very uh cutting, very effective. I don't know
if I think Pisco is the guy to do like the empathy like he said
the Dr. K conversations. I don't know if that's ever going to
be Pisco,
right? But I don't know if that ever should be Pisco. I don't
know if that's like his job. I don't know if that's what he's
most gifted at or like his how he should use his skill set in
the world. So that's that's what I I need to be convinced of
that more like what do you want to do with your channel and are
you on a path for that? Yeah, it's it really comes down to that
which I still don't know if that's been asked. Pisco, what do
you want? What does Pisco want? What is not to do the meme,
what is the world that Pisco wants of imagining that people have
this ideology or this like big round worldview, this sphere,
this like thing that they are. Think of them as what the reality
is, which is that they are like an idiosyncratic cluster of like
12 beliefs. One of them they got from conspiracy Tik Tok. One
of them they got from Facebook group. One of them they got from
their mom who's obsessed with vaccinations, whatever, right?
And these cluster together and you can no longer play the debate
game of my ideology beats your ideology. You you need to convert
to me now essentially or to their audience or whatever. You now
have to fight them on these individual smaller issues without
attempting to demand consistency across their worldview. You
should basically, so if you're not arguing about whether Trump
is good or bad, you should be okay with them maintaining that
Trump is good while you also combat their more urgent need to
not be antiax or to stop beating their wife or whatever, right?
Like focus. I feel like the thing the frustrating thing I see
with liberals every day is that they'll run into a wife beater
who's a flatearther and they will focus more heavily on the flat
earthing than the white beef wife beater. Even though no one
cares that the the world is round or flat, it doesn't actually
materially impact their day-to-day. But what does impact their
dayto-day is their wife getting beaten. So like like liberals
want to focus on the big wide ideological problems that they
have, the total disconnections from truth and reality. >> I
got to go to my door real quick. Just give me two seconds. I'm
listening. I'm listening. I'm listening. I'm listening. >> Instead
of focusing on the most important high priority issue and you
can fix that while saying, "Yeah, Trump has some good points."
You don't have to believe it. you can find the good points cuz
you know I'm sure you're smart enough to find something Trump
has said that you went well I guess I guess he's spitting there
fine you don't need that much in order to appeal to them to show
them that you are >> be nicer to MAGA I mean I'm trying
to actualize your advice how do I actualize
return he's going to get some clips and he's going to send them
to you and you're going to you know he's got to do some homework
and I appreciate the >> you want to know what Pisco needs
okay you want to know what Pisco needs if he wants to do this
he needs to go and follow around a salesman, okay? A really good
salesman, a shark salesman, okay? You know who's the most sensitive
to what other people want in the world? It's like a totally totally
psychopathic shark salesman, right? Who like he can zone in exactly
precisely
on the things other people want, right?
And and he he only sees the world through their eyes. That's
what that's what you need to like do effective political like
communication across political lines in my opinion. I don't know.
I don't know if everybody agrees with that. I feel like I feel
like you should be able to identify. You don't have to be a psychopath,
but I'm telling you there are people who will like lie and who
can adopt other people's worldview and can see what they want
and sell them what they want even when they know that they don't
have the thing. Right. Yeah. Yeah. >> I think we have this
conversation again. We can we can continue the conversation.
Send me those clips and and we'll break it down. But I appreciate
you coming on to chat. >> Yeah. Absolutely. Thanks, buddy.
>> And Erin, you seem cool. I'll check out your content
in the future. Um, I appreciate appreciate this guy for Shut
the [__] up telling us about you. Thank you so much.
>> Get out of here. >> All right. Give me a second.
I just got to go pee. All right. I'll be right >> Oh, yeah.
Yeah. I'm trying to adjust this thing. You know, he was so over
peace. Uh, >> is that Yoga Ball red? No. >> It's
about coming into that conversation and debating him on that.
But I'm completely fine with it. You know why I'm fine with it?
Because I get in, I'm like 2 minutes late. Not even to my own
show. How can I be late to my own show? Josiah is there. Hijacks
the convo. We're talking about >> turns it into Star Wars
every time. Make friends and influence people. It's how to win
friends and influence people. But yes. Yes. >> Star Wars
for some reason.
So, but what are we going to do next? Let's see. I got a couple
of clips that I want him to see before uh we get to her take.
>> But I'll see how much time he He doesn't have that much
time. We'll get we'll just get into her take. >> I think
we're good with this. We're good on this. I feel like we can
probably go over back to the econom boy stuff. There's one other
thing. What was it? I don't know. We got the econom boy stuff
right now. Go back to this. This is literally broken. Okay. Cool.
Cool, cool, cool, cool, cool. Where the [__]
>> really tinted red to the degree that you're describing.
I just like why would they engage in electoral politics like
that? Well, I would imagine I don't know if there's ever been
a survey on it, but I'd imagine that these 10% of people if if
I mean I'm assuming that number is correct. I don't know the
the fact of that, but if 10% of the people uh call themselves
socialists in the Democratic party, that those people's views
would be more aligned with the average socialist view that we
see online, which is all about abolishing private property and
abolishing capitalism. >> Never mind. Hold on. We got some
trouble in paradise.
Tim Dylan goes nuclear on Barry Weiss. I do want to see that.
I do love people yelling at Barry Weiss. Tim Dylan obliterates
Barry Weiss. $250 million valuation >> among the intellectual
dark web types. So, I don't know how many of you guys remember
this, but >> this guy, we love Kyle Kolinsky here. Okay,
Kuryoko, we love Kyle Kolinsky. Kyle's awesome. Remember when
that original article came out on the intellectual dark web and
you had was it like Joe Rogan and Sam Harris and Ben Shapiro
and Dave Rubin and um I think it was Barry Weiss who actually
uh I think it gets them viewership soap box. I think there's
a a lot of people who want to be told Jtock bad, you know, just
like Hassan bad. There's an industry. If there's an industry,
if there's a market for content, somebody will make it eventually.
Wrote that article back when she was with the New York Times.
And then since then, Barry Weiss left the New York Times and
she started this thing called the free press. She also started
a fake university called like University of Austin or Austin
University or something like that. And um you know it was big
on this self suck off session of like uh we believe in free speech
bro and like nobody else does but we do bro and then now all
of a sudden all these people morphed into like Trump defenders
and uh Zionist sickopants and they're just disgusting like all
these people and that's why the intellectual dark web effect
effectively collapsed and you got infighting going on over there.
Well now we got some more trouble in paradise. So Tim Dylan,
who of course is a Rogan sphere comedian who I've been given
a hard time lately because he's way too soft on Trump and uh
not seeing the
>> um I just find it funny that a lot of DJers are naturally
drawn to
content creators. There's like a pattern I'm sensing here is
very Hey, I I'm just seeing a pattern. It's a little concerning,
but maybe none of them feel >> Obvious reality of the Epstein
files that Trump is in the Epstein files and that's why he won't
release them. Um anyway, here you have Tim Dylan is going to
go after
Barry Weiss. Uh and it gets both funny and interesting. Let's
watch. >> The political fallout from this scandal would
be monumental and it would affect some of the wealthiest people
in the world and our relationships with different countries,
namely Israel.
I mean, unless we're all completely wrong here, and that Jeffrey
Epstein was not at all connected to the Messiah, but it it seems
he was.
It seems he was. So again, it would call into question this relationship
that we've had with our quote greatest ally for a very long time.
That can't >> too lazy to try videos. [__]
suck. Sorry. I've gotten to a point where it kind of just sucks
now. Doesn't do a good job >> happen. I don't care how
many you know Barry Weiss whose companies, you know, sold now
is going to sell to CBS for $3 trillion or something.
>> All right, let me now let me pause here to point out.
So Barry went independent, right? and did this free press thing.
And then now she got a knock on her door recently from CBS
and CBS
said to her, "We want you to be like a like a quality coordinator
or, you know, somebody who monitors the coverage over at CBS."
Now, stop and think about what's been happening at CBS recently.
>> What's been happening is they're they just got their
merger approved. They were trying desperately to get their merger
approved >> with, you know, Paramount with a bigger company,
right? and they went soft on Trump in order to do it. The head
of 60 Minutes stepped had to step down because he felt like he
was being muzzled and he couldn't tell the truth anymore. They
fired Steven Cobar because Steven Cobar mocks the president all
the time. Um, and the other thing is they didn't like how not
only anti-Trump
some of the stuff on CBS was, but also anti-Israel in the sense
that they're objectively covering the genocide of the Palestinian
people. And so CBS goes, "Bring in Barry Weiss. bring in Barry
Weiss to check
Bring in Barry Weiss to make sure that the coverage is sufficiently
pro- Israel. That's why they want to bring her in, right? And
so that and they're like Tim Dylan was saying, they want to pay
her like $250 million
for the free press. Let me tell you something, guys. The free
press has a fraction
of the the cultural sway and the numbers that this show gets.
I knew he's going to say, "Bro, where's my $250 million,
Kyle? All you got to do, Kyle, you're on the wrong side of a
one issue. You're one issue away from a $250 million check, Kyle,
today.
We'll hook you up." >> Is my if she's worth $250 million.
Is my show worth what? $750 million. If somebody wants to buy
it, are you kidding me? This is It's all fake. It's fake. It's
fake. This is all fake. This is literally like like big money
interests just throwing a a quarter of a billion dollars at Barry
Weiss to police the discourse when it comes to Israel and Palestine
to make sure you don't let the media go too pro Palestine and
call the genocide out for what it is. That's literally the whole
point. So Tim Dylan is about to tee off on that fact. >> You
know Barry Weiss whose company is you know sold now he's going
to sell to CBS for $3 trillion or something. Larry Ellison's
son's buying the free press, you know, the very uh the very uh
important free press blog that uh on Substack is worth $250 million.
And I like Barry, but the free, you know, the one that gets like
7,500 views on YouTube, that powerhouse conglomerate media company
is worth $250 million, by the way. Dude, there's got to be something
else associated, right? The free press. There's got to be something
else. Come on. How could there How would there not be something
else, dude? They barely get any engagement on their [__]
105 comments, 60 comments, 42 comments. No way. 250 million,
dude. What? I I don't understand, but okay. >> So, the
Tim Dylan show worth a billion. >> Hello, Miriam. Where's
my money? $300 million a quarter bill. >> I I know. So,
I know that they probably shouldn't be Some of you guys are framing
it as like a Trump thing. Tim Dylan doesn't seem to think it's
a Trump thing. That was Okay. I become prolific in understanding
>> anti-zionist
anti quote unquote anti-ionist talking points. Okay. >> 50
million by the way. So the Tim Dylan show is apparently worth
a billion. Hello M.
>> So that that do we all know who that is? That is of
course Miriam Adlesen, wife, widow of Sheldon Adlesen, infamous
famous casino owner and Republican mega donor who is also infamously
a massive like uh Israel simp. Israel citiz Israeli citizen pretty
much just supports whoever is going to support Israel, right?
She went to bat for Nikki Haley in the primaries, I believe,
cuz Nikki Haley was ready to go to war with Iran right away.
Where's my money? $300 million, a quarter billion dollars for
Barry Weiss's blog in which he interviewed mear Ross Douet from
the New York Times about why conspiracies have taken the hold
of the American mind. And Ross goes, "Well, you know, the thing
about conspiracies is there's an element of truth." Not in this
one. There's not an element of truth. It's that it's all truth.
It's all the elements of all of the truth. >> Talking about
Epstein, >> it's not a kernel of truth. >> Wait,
she doesn't own the Mavericks, now does she? There's no way.
There's no way
that she bought the Dallas Mavericks and traded Luca to LA. There's
no way. The trading of Luca was a Zionist plot.
No way.
Holy. We really can blame the juice for everything. I'm just
kidding. That's a joke. That's a joke. It's just satire. That's
not serious. It was just a little joke. We throw in a little
light humor once in a while. >> Truth. It's lots of kernels
in a bag of popcorn. But there's a two. But this is why and every
article now is like why have conspiracies
the minds of people are being warped? They're melting because
of the conspira. So you know again and everyone talks about like
every like oh the grift is to go against Israel. It's like clearly
not. The the grift is a quart million dollars for the blog. Yes.
The grift is
That's where the money is. Barry Weiss has always been anti Palestine.
They ran some disgusting ass articles. The question, oh, are
people really starving in Gaza?
This is what they do. This is what it's pro- Israel.